- Oh my God!
Connor, Joey!
What are those amazing
mugs you've got there?
- Sorry, I couldn't hear you
over the staring at my beautiful mug!
The Trash Taste Mug,
with a lid!
- Oh my God!
- Oh my God,
is that the Trash Taste Mug
that you can get from TrashTasteMugs.com?
- And, there's only
two weeks left as well.
- There's only two weeks left, gentlemen.
- Well, I better snatch my mug now.
There's only two weeks left.
At TrashTasteMugs.com
(Joey gasps)
- It comes with a lid!
- $29.99 plus shipping.
Two weeks left, and once
the two weeks are gone,
they're gone forever.
So, you better go to it right now,
and snag it if you haven't yet.
- Oh my God.
I wish I just knew
about TrashTasteMugs.com
to get these mugs right now.
- I'm just so grateful that
I have a perfectly sized mug
for any beverage of my wanting.
- And, it's got a lid so you
can keep cold things cold
and warm things warm.
(Garnt laughing)
- Joey just explained science.
Back to the episode.
(Joey beatboxing)
- Fucking love that meme.
- I'm literally cumming.
(Joey beatboxing)
- I just want to cum.
- Here we go!
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to this episode
of "Trash Taste" with me,
your host Connor, and
the boys, Joey and Garnt.
- That's us.
- Yes, that's us.
- Now--
- Nice of you
to be hosting the manga episode, right?
- I was going to get into that, Garnt.
- Okay.
- We're all gentlemen here.
We're all connoisseurs of the fine arts.
We all read words.
- You know the Trash Taste law.
You know our character development,
- Yeah.
- And you know,
the best reader of all
time is obviously Connor.
- Exactly.
- That's true.
I am reading.
That's it.
- Librarians wish they could
have Connor's brain right now.
- They wish they could access
this fountain of knowledge.
(Joey laughing)
- And we thought obviously,
the best host for the
manga-centric episode,
which we are going to be doing today-
- We don't choose hosts, Garnt.
(Garnt laughing)
It's a rotation.
- Yeah, and it just, the stars aligned.
They were sending us a message,
it's like, "It's Connor's turn."
- Connor must host.
- Do the manga episode.
- This episode.
Yeah, so that's what we're doing today.
- I like how you've hosted
the Doujins episode as well,
I just realized by complete chance.
And now, you've also hosted
the manga episode, right?
- What can I say, I read.
- Yeah.
(everybody laughing)
- I'm somewhat of a reader myself.
Anyway, yeah as we've said,
this is the manga episode of "Trash Taste"
where we're going to be
discussing our favorite mangas
on our favorite preferred methods.
It's going to be the three-by-three,
which you see on there.
- We've talked about manga in the past
in a lot of different episodes,
but I don't think we've
actually established
what our all-time favorite mangas,
or like our manga "tastes", quote unquote.
- Yeah, it's really weird
because when we were thinking
about what haven't we
specifically talked about
on theme in an episode?
And I was like, "Wait a minute,
we've never talked about manga."
And for some reason, I just
assumed that we already had.
- Yeah.
- Because it feels like we have, right?
- Yeah, yeah definitely.
- But like, it just was like-
- I was like, we did the anime one
so obviously we did the
manga ones as well, right?
- Yeah, right.
- And of course, I was thinking
about the fact that
I wonder, because the movie
one that we did recently
is probably going to have
a lot more variation.
I feel like there must
be some more overlap
this time, right?
- Yeah, I really don't know.
- Like there's one or two where I'm like,
"I'm pretty sure if it's not on your list,
you would put it on your list anyway."
- There's at least one I
know that I probably...
I mean you're kind of limited in your...
I mean you're so expansive.
- I mean, I know I've
probably got at least one
that's the same as you.
I think I might have one that's
the same as Joey as well.
- Here's what I realized
when I recently read
"Records of Ragnarok."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Is that I've only read
really long running manga.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Right.
- I don't think I've read a single manga
that had like less than 150 chapters.
- I would actually agree with you on that.
Okay so I realized when
picking my three-by-three
is that there isn't that much choice
or there isn't as much choice as there is
in the anime world, right?
Of like manga that really
left a deep impression on me.
And that's because like manga,
if you watch a season of anime,
it actually takes less time to consume it
than reading a really,
long running manga series.
Because if it's like a one shot,
or like a one volume kind of thing,
it probably was not going to leave
that deep of an effect on me.
- I don't know, man.
I've read a lot of one
shots that were like,
"man, this is dead-ass better
than some like twenty
chapter plus like shows."
- Yeah, like the "Death
Note Donald Trump" one shot.
(everyone laughing)
That was good.
That left an impression on me.
I didn't expect to see manga Donald Trump,
but...
- True that.
And we saw it in the
best art-style as well.
- Yeah yeah.
- Give him a fucking fist pump to Ryoku.
(group laughing)
- Honestly, that one
shot, I didn't realize-
- It's amazing.
- I didn't realize how
much I missed "Death Note"
until I read that one shot.
And I was like,
"Damn we kinda need a
sequel to 'Death Note'."
- He was just playing with us.
That's the worst part is that it was like,
the Pro coming back and
just styling on everyone
and then being like, "See you by the way."
(group laughing)
You know what I mean?
Just being like, "I could come back,
I could kill it."
- It's like that villain wrestler,
who just comes in
clotheslines, then leaves.
(group laughing)
- Builds all your furniture.
Leaves.
It's like, "Oh shit, okay, that was cool."
- Oh cool, thank you.
- But then I also realized
making this three-by-three
is that I really haven't read
as much manga as I have watched anime.
I mean, I'm unfortunately
not the manga man.
That's probably Joey, right?
- [Connor] I think in your head
you feel like manga is easier?
Maybe, because you can speak...
You can read Japanese fluently.
Maybe it is,
because you can just pick them up.
You can just go to the
store, pay two bucks,
get the manga, and you're good to go.
- I mean, as someone
called, "The Anime Man",
I obviously read a lot more manga
than I watch anime.
- Yeah, you read more manga
As we all know by now.
- Go figure.
- The running meme.
And I do think that if that was the case,
I think I would probably read more.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But I think because of
the fact that I'm not...
I do enjoy reading digitally.
I like the ease of it,
but I do find that it's a little more,
I don't know, it feels harder to get into.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know why.
- Did you mean digitally?
- Yeah.
When I'm reading it, I like it.
- But it's getting into it
where I'm like, I don't know.
Because when you see it in
the store, you can pick it up,
you can flick through.
You're like, "Oh, okay."
- There's no better feeling
than like a physical page turner.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
That's how you really get into it.
Especially with manga
because, unlike normal books,
you have to actually just read it.
Manga it pops right out.
You can see, oh, okay well damn, okay.
- You can look at it close-by as well.
- It just feels right.
It feels much better.
- It feels like I'm reading.
You know what I mean?
It really feels like I'm reading.
- [Connor] Right.
- Just something about it.
- It feels more special,
and it feels a bit more intimate, I guess.
I guess like most of the manga
that I put on my three-by-three,
I actually read on paper.
- Oh okay.
- And I feel like,
I don't know if that's
a complete coincidence.
Some of them...
Some manga I know are really good
and I purposely will not read it
unless it's physical copies.
- Yeah
Other manga, I kind of maybe read online
and if it's like good,
then I try and go out of my
way to buy physical copies.
- Yeah, but I mean, like I was saying,
I think that for me at least a little bit,
anime is slightly easier to consume.
It really depends.
I don't really understand
how I consume manga.
- It depends on...
- I don't really get it.
I like to think I
understand, but I don't think
I get what I'm doing.
- It depends on the
series for me, definitely.
Like there are some where it's just like,
I really fucking struggled
to like get into the manga.
But for some reason it's
really easy to watch the anime
and vice versa.
- Yeah also another thing
when I was picking my three-by-three
is that I tried not to pick titles
that already had like
a big anime adaptation
or something that I watched the anime,
and I feel like it
doesn't make a difference.
- So you're trying to be that guy of like,
"I don't watch the main, I
don't read the mainstream."
- No, because like...
- Trying to be artsy boy
- For example like,
I don't think there's any point
in me putting "One Piece,"
on my three-by-three.
- As good as the manga reads, right.
- Because the manga-
- I feel fucking haunted with everyone
asking me, "Why haven't I started it yet?"
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, because like the manga is amazing,
but I feel like, with that,
you could either read the
manga or watch the anime,
and you could either have like a good
experience on each and
as long as you put it-
- I don't think there's a single person
watching "Trash Taste"
that doesn't know what "One Piece" is.
- Yeah, and I'm just like,
"Do I really need to tell
my 'Trash Taste' viewers
that I am a 'One-Piece' fan?"
Like dude, do you really
need to know that?
- I was in my Japanese class this morning.
And they was like,
they made me listen to
like Japanese people speak,
and tell them what they were saying.
And I got totally thrown
off in one audio clip
because there was a woman
talking about her dress,
but it's one piece.
- One piece!
- And I was like, "oh, she
likes red 'One Piece'?"
(laughing)
What?
I was like so thrown,
and I couldn't listen to the rest of it
because I'm like, "Did
she just say 'One Piece'?
Like the anime?
Shit, she's a bit of a weeb."
- And you just like the
PTSD of the internet.
And you're just like-
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah
I was like "One Piece!"
(Connor grunting excitedly)
I can't escape it!
- I remember like...
When I was first getting into "One Piece,"
I really wanted to buy the manga volumes.
So obviously anime-
- You typed 'One Piece.'
- Yeah yeah, I typed
in 'One Piece' on eBay
and I'm just like,
"Don't give me a fucking
dress, I want the manga.
Give me the manga."
And I scroll down.
It's just like dress,
dress, dress, dress, dress.
It's like, goddammit.
- All right, gentlemen.
It's time.
- Okay.
- All right.
Trash box can decide it all.
Man, we got some real mileage out of this.
Dollar, dollar...
- Thanks Navvy you're the real MVP here.
- [Male Speaker] He's my son.
(item jiggling in container)
- 4K hearing.
- 4K trash box good.
- [Joey] Who's going first?
- All right.
First up, let me get the trash.
- [Garnt] All right.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- First up is, Connor spelled incorrectly.
- Conner.
- Who did this?
Someone's getting fired.
- [Garnt] Conner.
- [Joey] Conner.
- It's an 'O'!
(group laughing)
I'm kidding.
Yeah I'm first.
I think I've actually only read,
coincidentally, like nine manga.
- I can probably name all
nine that you've read.
- Well you don't need to cheat.
- Wait, wait, wait can we make a guess?
Can we make a guess before,
before you show them?
- [Joey] Do we want to?
- I'm not going to confirm
if you're right or wrong.
You can just say.
- Okay, okay.
- All right.
- Well obviously "Jojo."
- "Jojo: Part Seven."
- Yeah.
- "Berserk."
- Yup.
- "Claymore?"
(Joey laughing)
- "Eyeshield 21."
- "Eyeshield", "Gantz."
- "Gantz."
- That's five.
- "Records of Ragnarok?"
- No, that wouldn't be in there.
(Joey laughing)
There's something... what's what's like.
- There's something else.
- What's the cockroach one again?
- Oh, "Terraform!"
- [Garnt] Oh, "Terraform."
- Oh shit, I didn't put that on.
- Oh.
- Oh damn!
(Garnt laughing)
- We'll talk about that.
- Yeah.
- We'll talk about that as well.
What else has he read?
"Vinland Saga?"
- Yeah, "Vinland Saga."
- That's seven.
I can't think of any more, that he's read.
- "Death Note" maybe?
- Maybe.
- Did you read "Death Note" or watch it?
- I think he watched it.
- All right, okay, you know what?
Let's find out.
- We've got, we've got seven.
- You're going to kick
yourself when you missed,
you missed one that you're
going to be like, "Of course."
- I know there's one that's
like, very obviously we missed.
- All right Ashley pull it up.
Put it up.
- Put it up on the screen.
- [Joey] Oh "One Punch Man."
- [Connor] Yeah "One Punch Man."
- [Garnt] Oh "One Punch Man" of course.
- [Joey] Oh and "Black Butler."
Oh and...
(Joey laughing)
- [Garnt] "You Are My Princess!"
- So I just got to do a bit
of self promo here real quick.
I love this manga so much that
I made an audio book of it.
You can go buy it by
the way on Book Walker.
- [Garnt] Oh my god.
- "You Are My Princess"
full audio book edition
is available.
- We do not condone of this self promo.
- Yeah I wasn't allowed to do this,
but I'm going to do it again
anyway, just by the way.
It's actually okay.
- That's where "Terraformers" would go.
- Yeah.
- Okay, okay we'll get into Terra...
I'll quickly, actually I will...
Let me touch on this.
It's actually, genuinely,
a really good BL story.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- If you ever want to get
into BL, it's good, man.
It's about a guy who's like, "Yeah, dude.
I like this guy, but I don't,
I don't know this isn't normal.
Right?"
But then he, but then yeah,
he really likes the guy.
(dramatic squeal)
- That's literally every Yaoi.
- Yeah.
- No, a lot of them are really rapey.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
- A lot of them are like,
"Oh, you don't like me.
Well, let me make you cum and
that'll change your mind."
And it's like...
- Cyber punk music playing!
- It's like, hold on, wha, what?
(Joey laughing)
It's like isn't this, isn't this...
and then everyone's like,
"No no, don't say it."
- [Joey] No no.
- It's not weird.
It's only weird if you make it weird.
- Shut up, it's hot.
- But it's actually a
really wholesome manga.
And yeah, if you want to listen
to it in audio book form,
you can officially license.
- Anyway, do you want
to go through the list
in case there are some that..
- In case we didn't, mention them already?
- Yep, so you've got most of them, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] "Claymore", "One
Punch Man", "Beserk", "Jojo",
"Black Butler", "Gantz", "Vinland
Saga", and "Eyeshield 21."
- I wasn't expecting "Black
Butler" there for some reason.
- Actually, I-
- Yeah.
- I thought you were more
of a fan of the anime.
- I didn't realize you
read the manga of that.
- Yeah.
- I've read, what
chapter did I read up to?
I've read a good chunk of "Black Butler."
I haven't caught up.
'Cause I know that a
bunch of shit happened
and there's a lot of big plot
twists that I know about,
but I haven't read yet.
- [Garnt] Right.
- But I've read most of "Black Butler"
and it's so, so much better
in manga format than anime.
(Joey laughing)
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Really?
- Okay, the first season is
basically like kind of like a,
I don't know, episodical
slice of life kind of thing.
That doesn't really progress
the story that much.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Connor] And the second
season is just non-canonical-
- Right, right.
- [Connor] of "Black Butler."
(Connor laughing)
- It's so bad, sorry.
(incoherent chatter)
- [Connor] Water just fell down.
- [Garnt] I just dripped on myself again.
- Did you miss your mouth?
(group laughing)
- Cue another montage of me not
being able to drink liquids.
- It's a shame, right.
'Cause it's the whole meme, right.
I kind of, I don't really talk about it
'cause I don't want to be.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know people will
kind of want to be like,
"Oh, he's the 'Black Butler' guy."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I don't mind talking about it now.
But yeah, the third
season of "Black Butler,"
the anime is based on like
the manga and it's amazing.
Like it's like a really morbid part.
It's really dark and you kind
of realize how good it can be.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But yeah, the manga is a
really, really good, good read.
And I'd recommend it if
you kind of like the idea
of "Black Butler,"
but don't want to go
through with the anime.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I wouldn't have read it
if it wasn't for my YouTube videos.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, because like I've
heard the second season of
"Black Butler," is that
different from the manga?
- Yeah, it's totally...
- That's what I heard.
- They just made it up.
- I think it's an anime original, yeah.
- It's completely terrible.
It's universally like hated.
- Okay.
- But like genuinely, you
give the manga a shot,
it's pretty good.
- So what's like,
different about the manga
than the anime that you would
recommend the manga over it?
- Well, it's like way more serious,
way more like it doesn't like fuck around
and it doesn't really feel like,
cause the anime very much
feels like it's kind of just,
Yaoi bait at times.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Like it just feels like-
- It's definitely trying to
pertain towards its audience.
- Yeah and it's very, and
the first season, again,
it's very casual.
It doesn't really...
it does cover a lot of the same things,
but it does it in a way that
I've just, I think, okay, eh.
- I watched season one of the anime,
and I thought it was like...
- It's fun.
It's fun.
But manga does it so much better.
- Yeah.
- It does it so much more justice.
- And I feel Toboso Yana's,
like, art style was a lot
just like more gritty and like kinda dark.
- It's so good.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But she gets better as
well and it's so good.
And the third season of
"Black Butler" covers
like a circus arc and it's so good.
And the anime does it justice.
- Book of cir...
- Book of Circus.
- Book of Circus, yeah.
- And it's actually so good.
- So is like the anime finished now?
Or, is the manga finished, sorry.
- I think the manga is still going.
- The manga is still ongoing.
- Oh it's still going!
- It's still going, yeah.
It's quite long running
and I don't know how many volumes are on.
I think we're over like 13 at this point.
I think it's quite...
- I think it's way more than that.
- Yeah quite a lot.
- I think it's like over 20 now.
- Is it really over 20?
Fuck, I think I've only
read up to like 10.
- [Joey] Right.
- But I really enjoyed it.
I don't know why I stopped.
I'm probably going to
read it at some point.
- [Garnt] Yep.
- Because you know when you
catch up to a certain point,
you're like, "I'm done."
- [Garnt] Yeah because-
- [Connor] I don't know.
I don't know what I want to do.
- Yeah because for me,
my manga reading habits
is that I just love binge
reading manga so much.
- Yeah, same.
I can't, once I start
a manga, I can't stop.
- Oh, we're on volume 30 now.
- Volume 30 of "Black Butler!"
- I know I've read over half I think.
- [Joey] Right.
- But I don't know how long ago that was,
because I think what was happening is
I got really burned out on it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because I read so much of it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- In like the space of a week.
- And your entire career
was consistently that.
- Yeah and then, then that happened.
Then I got...
Which I think this is probably
going to remind me to get back into it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because with "One
Punch," I did that as well,
which we'll talk about later.
- Yeah.
- But genuinely I think, even though
if you've seen the show,
I would give it a shot.
- Yeah I've definitely,
I did remember giving
the "Black Butler" manga a go.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like after I finished
watching season one,
because I had just, at that point,
season two had already finished
airing and I just heard,
"Don't watch season two."
So I was like, all right.
Time for the manga then.
And then I just never got to it.
- Yeah.
And there's some...
It's really, really dark at times.
Like you forget like the main premise
is that in "Black Butler,"
he's a demon and that he's
made a contract with him
to have his life at the end.
And like, they kind of play off it a lot
in the anime and make it seem like,
"Oh, oh, it's kind of hot, hot.
Mmm okay."
You know?
(group laughing)
But yeah, in the manga,
they constantly remind you sometimes like,
"Oh shit.
He just like, murders people."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like straight up.
And they're not afraid of like showing
like really morbid stuff.
- [Joey] Damn.
- There's some really
good plot twist, you know?
Like I won't spoil some of them,
but there's some really fucked
up shit that happens in that.
- [Joey] Okay okay.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's really worth giving it a shot,
even though all the
stereotypes, not stereotypes,
but the... what's the word?
- Facade, I guess.
- Facade or the preconceptions
that a lot of the Western anime fans have.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because I think in Japan,
it's pretty fucking popular I think.
- Oh yeah.
It is.
But it's popular, but it definitely does
have like a strong female audience.
- Yeah I mean, Sebastian is iconic.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I mean being the sexy man of anime.
- I mean he was like the sexy man of anime
for like the early to mid 2000's.
- I'd still argue if you make a list
of top five sexiest anime
characters, Sebastian's on there.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- He is just sexy.
Yeah, British!
- He just has that like cult following.
- Lets hit the pubs lads.
(group laughing)
- It's "Black Butler" innit.
- Like he's just an icon of his time.
For like anime and manga at the time.
Like for like...there's a few,
like I'd say characters in like anime
that just personified a
certain character trait.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like you think of
Yandere for our generation,
it's fucking Yuna Gasa,
you know what I mean?
You think sexy man, it's
Sebastian from "Black Butler."
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I don't think anyone's replaced him yet.
- [Connor] Yeah, no.
- I mean the one that got close
was maybe like Yuri from "Yuri On Ice."
- Yeah, but even then like-
- Even then.
- Even then, yeah, yeah.
- I don't think he's as
charming as Sebastian, yeah.
- It's the staple.
Sebastian is just a staple of like,
it's like the sexy butler,
but also just very
suave, very charismatic.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- He is very entertaining
and I feel like Sebastian,
it does carry a lot of the time
because it was just so fun.
And even though he is
like obedient, he's just,
he makes it so entertaining.
- [Joey] Yeah.
And you know, again, even my videos,
I didn't even remotely do him justice.
He's such a,
he's so witty and so clever in the anime,
in the manga, sorry.
Where it's just it's so
he's so fun to watch.
And the, you know, the third
season of the anime is good
and the Book of Murder,
I think it's called, is that correct?
Book of Murder is pretty fun.
It's like kind of like a mini who done it.
- [Joey] Right.
- Within like in like two hours.
It's pretty fun.
- That's cool.
- Yeah, and it's obviously
Sebastian solves everything
and does it magically which is always fun.
Cause it's like-
- My man!
- Because it's like,
what if Sakamoto became a
butler later on in life?
That is,
that is Sebastian.
- I feel like Sebastian and Sakamoto
are just like twins separated at birth.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, they are
literally the same person.
Like Sakamoto is just Sebastian in school.
Like because they literally
have the same kind
of like...
Maybe Sakamoto is a little
more tongue in cheek.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But Sebastian very much has
the same kind of visual humor
a lot of the time.
And does like a lot of, you know,
the joke is often that he is
just so insanely competent
that everything is-
- Right, right.
- Just so OP.
- He's literally OP as
fuck, but it's amazing.
Like it's so good.
I just love it.
It's so, and it's,
I feel like there's not a manga
that has the same feeling
as "Black Butler."
I don't think there's a single
manga that feels like it.
Or anime show that it has
the same kind of vibe.
- Yeah.
I feel it definitely like created a staple
for that kind of genre.
- [Connor] For sure.
- Like there's probably a lot of manga
that's imitating "Black Butler."
- [Connor] A hundred
percent, hundred percent.
- Yeah.
- Because there's not many manga out there
that do like deal with
like pretty intense themes.
They have like all these
like thriller aspects.
They also have the, you know,
the parts that appeal to the
Fuja, it's quite a lot, right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So it kind of mixes a
lot of genres together.
And I think even Yana Tobaso herself said
that she didn't even know
what genre she'd put it in
because it's so, it
touches on so many genres
throughout the manga.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's why I think it's
super unique and worth reading.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Did you watch the anime
or read the manga first?
- Anime first.
- Okay.
I should've expected that actually.
- So anime,
I watched the anime and, you know,
I thought...
I just watched it and I
thought it was kind of meh.
It was kind of boring.
(Connor laughing)
I thought it was okay.
I thought season two was God awful.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
And at this time Book of
Circus hadn't came out yet.
And basically I did that
and then someone was like,
"Oh, you should,
you should just do like
character impressions
for my YouTube channel."
I was like "Oh, okay."
And I did a few
and then Sebastian just
happened to be the one
that I tried first,
and I thought I sounded nothing like him.
(Joey laughing)
- Posh British Butler guy, right?
- Yeah, everyone's like,
"Oh my god it's him!"
But then looking back, I'm like,
it doesn't even sound like
Jay Michael Taylor at all,
but you know,
I'm sure he was offended
that people were comp-
I'd be offended.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And then I did that and
then I got, you know,
I got surrounded by people who loved it
and kept like telling me,
read it, read it, read it.
And I was like reluctant.
I was like, no.
- So wait what was,
what was the first manga you ever read?
Is it on the three-by-three?
That you like distinctly, remember.
- It might've been "Black But"-
No, it must have been "Black Butler."
Yeah, it must've was "Black Butler."
It was Black Butler and I didn't read any
for like two years.
(Joey laughing)
- He just thought "manga
equals 'Black Butler.'"
- Because I, the reason
why I actually got into it,
I remember this now,
'cause I did a manga dub of part of the,
I can't remember what
the boat arc's called.
The Campania Arc?
Campaign?
- Just the boat arc.
- The boat arc.
- The Book of Atlantic, is it?
Book of Atlantic maybe is what it's called
because they made a movie about it.
I haven't watched the movie.
I did a comic dub of a portion of that.
And so yeah,
I just ended up reading
it because I was like,
"Oh, this arc looks cool."
And I had it out of context.
And I was like, "Oh,
okay, well this is cool.
I'm going to go read the rest."
And I start reading it and
I read it past that point.
And then I stopped.
- [Joey] Right.
- But everything before I enjoyed it.
But I'm probably going to go finish it.
- Yeah, because what I want to know
is that I'm looking at most of these
and I'd say a lot of these
have come from recommendations
literally from us telling you
to go like go out and read it.
- I know exactly which
ones Garnt recommended.
I know which ones I recommended.
- So do it in the order of
I watched them, I read them.
- Yeah, yeah go for it.
- Okay so next up was "One Punch Man."
- Okay.
- Yeah so what inspired you
to read "One Punch Man?"
- I guess the anime, right?
- Season one was too good.
Like how can you, you can't
cock block me like that, right?
Like season one was so
good and I saw the manga
and I was like, "Oh."
A lot of the times when I'd see the manga
and when I wanted to go
further, like past the anime,
I would start reading the
manga and I'd be like,
"Eh, it's not the same."
But "One Punch" was the
one where I was like,
"Holy shit this is insane."
Like this, this artwork is just insane.
- Yeah, I noticed you have
two Murate Yusuke manga.
- Yeah, I love his art man.
His art is something.
- He's a beast.
- And he's so good at
visually conveying like-
- Action.
- Action and also just kind
of like metaphors I've seen.
- God, yeah.
Let's talk about...
I swear, like, because I think
especially in sports anime.
Sports anime, a lot of times,
live and die by the metaphor.
- Yeah.
- Right because how can you-
- Because concepts need to be explained.
- Yeah yeah.
'Cause like how can you convey
a certain move or certain like aspect
of a sport that people who are,
do not understand a sport
can easily understand.
You go for metaphors.
And by far the manga
that does the best visual
metaphors is "Eyeshield 21."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Fuck your "Haikyuu" and your
fucking crows or whatever.
- This is why I would want
him to do a chess anime.
He would explain the concept of chess
through metaphors amazingly.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- He'd be like, "This is a pen."
And he'd figure out some weird
fucking way of showing it.
I would love that, but sadly,
it's not popular in Japan, chess.
Big RIP.
But yeah, "One Punch Man."
I just like, dude, this
one was, still to this day,
one of my favorite mangas.
Out of all of these,
I still think that "One Punch Man"
is maybe one of my favorites.
Fuck it's so hard.
It's-
- Yeah, that's the difficult one,
because you have "Jojo" there as well.
- Because "Jojo" is there as well.
And I think "Jojo" might
be my favorite obviously,
but I think "Jojo" is my fave is like,
'cause I have a difference
between my favorite
and the one I enjoyed the most.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And I think I enjoyed
"One Punch Man" the most
because it was just pure fun.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But "Jojo" is my favorite
because there's so much
about Jojo that I love.
And I love the style of Jojo.
I love all of that.
And I feel like Jojo's so
much more than just the manga.
It's an experience.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's not just a manga, it's the culture.
- You know, you don't just read "Jojo"-
- You live it.
- You live it, you experience it.
You become Jojo.
- There's just something about "Jojo"
which we'll talk about later.
But just there's something about it.
But "One Punch Man", man,
like I finished season one
and I was like, "Okay,
I'm going to check it out.
I'm going to see what happens after."
'Cause it ends...
Because I mean, after you
watched the Boros Fight,
which you know, if you haven't,
if you don't know what "One Punch Man" is,
I'm going to explain it to you.
It's a guy who beats
everyone in one punch.
That's literally it.
- And he's a man.
- And at the end of the
season one of the anime,
he has this amazing fight
that is so visually
stunning and just amazing.
And it's so hype,
it's probably one of the coolest
animated fights in anime.
And I was like, "Okay, I have
to know where this can go."
Because everyone's saying
the story's amazing onwards.
So I started reading it
and I was like, "Oh, okay.
This is pretty cool."
The next arc starts.
And I'm like, "Okay, this
is really interesting."
- [Joey] Yeah yeah.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Because we start the what's known,
as the Monster Arc.
- And the Garoah arc.
- Garoah, yeah.
- And they introduced
Garoah, which is like
one of the main characters going forward
in the anime and manga
and season two covers
I probably say the beginning.
Just barely the beginning of one of the...
- It's a long arc, yeah.
- It's very long, it's
still ongoing on the manga.
Yeah, I started reading it and I was like,
"Goddamn, this man's drawings
are just another level."
Like actually insane.
- It's insane because I
remember reading "One Punch Man"
before the anime came out because
everyone was hyping it up.
So I was like, it was the
one show when I'm just like,
"Let me just, let me just see.
Let me just read like a
chapter or two just to see."
- You can't read a chapter or two.
- What can I, what I can expect.
So I tried reading a chapter or two
and then I read everything that was out.
- You can't.
You can't pick that up
and not read everything.
It's impossible.
- And then I remember
reading it and being like,
"There's no way the anime is
going to live up to this hype."
I was just like, "There's no fucking way."
But like not because the art is like,
I think some of the best
art that's available.
I mean-
- Dude when you turn...
There's a panel, right?
Where Sitoma punches so
hard, the clouds split.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And in this panel, you
like the detail on the Earth
and the clouds is insane.
- Yeah, no, there's some panels
that are literally just
animated key frames.
Where you read it and
it's, it's just like,
it's just like an anime
because it's just basically
key frames, right?
So like, I was very, very
impressed at, you know,
the team at Madhouse for being
able to put their own spin
on his amazing, fucking art.
Like living up to this amazing art.
But even without that, "One
Punch Man" is some of the best
battle shonen in like-
- Hundred percent.
- Art that you can find
in all of anime and manga.
- Yeah.
And I think that I'm very glad
that "One Punch Man" season one
was animated the way there was
because I think anime season
one is more of a comedy
and then season two onwards is an action.
I feel like the comedy
very much takes a backseat
after the first arc.
- Well yeah because I mean
you can only do so much
with that single concept right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
But like the way that they
made it work every time
was so genius and funny.
Like "One Punch Man" season one
is one of the funniest shows in anime.
- Yeah I agree.
- And in the manga,
I feel that although
the art is much better,
I feel like the comedy doesn't hit as hard
because the comedic timing
is super important for jokes.
And I feel like you can't have
as good comedic timing when
you're reading something as
when you were experiencing it.
The joke.
I think it's just like
a different experience
or a different like-
- It's a different type of comedy.
- [Connor] But a joke read
aloud will always be funnier
than a joke you've read.
Like that's just-
(Garnt exclaiming hesitation)
- I don't know.
- I disagree.
- I thought that too
until I read like stuff like "Gin Tama."
- Yeah but I've bet the "Gin Tama" animes
delivers the lines funnier.
- I dunno.
It's hard to say.
Like sometimes it does, yes.
But then there are some chapters that I...
I think "Gin Tama" is the only manga
that's genuinely made me
laugh out loud reading it.
And that's like a very
powerful thing to say right?
'Cause like, again,
it's like, as you said,
a joke is much funnier said out loud.
- Yeah.
But it's like timing, timing, you know,
have anything playing into the joke.
There's so many aspects that can help
elevate the joke in anime.
- I think that comes down
to, at least with manga,
how good you are at like framing, right.
And I think Munata Yuske is
so fucking good at framing
like a concept that he can just
somehow do that with comedy
as well.
Like he already proved it with
"Eyeshield 21's", like, action scenes.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And he,
this man can also do comedy as well.
I'm like, "What can this man not do?"
- Yeah.
I've read the original one rap comic.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How was that?
- Yeah.
It's, it's a, it's a lot harder to go to.
(group laughing)
But also I noticed-
- [Joey] So explain one can't draw.
That's why he got (indistinct)
- [Connor] So the original, yeah,
the original "One Punch
Man" is a web comic.
I'm sure you guys know this.
It's a web comic and then
Murata Yusuke picked it up
and was like, "Hey, let
me draw good for you."
Like real good.
And then published in Shonnen, not Jump,
it used to be Jump, right?
- Jump Plus.
- Jump Plus now.
It's once a month, which is painful
because I think Wandered Weekly...
Is... I believe the web
comics over now, right?
Is it?
- Kind of, I guess it's not
over, it's just on hiatus.
- [Connor] Oh okay.
- Because I've read up to everything
that's out and it's just kind of
in the middle of an arc right now.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But like the manga right
now is adapting its so-
- It's in the monster arc still.
- Yeah, it's still in the monster arc.
So it's taken the web
comic as kind of like a,
like a basis, and just
really expanding on that.
- Yeah.
I've noticed because
they've in the differences
between the manga and the web comic
is that they've put aspect
of the story that happened.
They've moved them around in the manga
into like better timings.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Like there's some characters
that got their backstory
in the web comic a certain
time that they were shifted
to them when they were having a fight,
they got the flashback and the backstory,
like there's a superhero
called Super Black Alloy.
(group laughing)
Who is a man that is super muscular.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's his thing.
And he gets his flashback
in a different time.
But in the actual, the redone manga,
he gets it during one of
his fights with Garoah.
- [Joey] Right.
- Which I noticed was like, "Oh, okay.
That's interesting."
I didn't know they were
mixing things around.
- [Joey] Right.
- But yeah, the manga is, oh my God,
just take one look at some of these panels
and you'll be, yeah, you'll
be reading it for sure.
- Yeah.
- It's definitely one
of the best action manga
I've ever read.
If not the best, honestly.
- Yeah it's hard.
I can't think of anything that
in terms of just pure action
and fights that comes close in mind.
I mean but I haven't read
many, so I can't say it,
but (indistinct)-
- I mean I still think
it's one of the best.
- It's definitely one of the best.
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- Fuck we started.
(Joey laughing)
- [Garnt] Using the
internet without ExpressVPN
is like taking a call on
the train or bus on speaker
for everyone to hear.
And who wants to do that?
- No one.
- Joey did you know that your
internet service provider
can see every single website you visit?
- You're joking.
- No, I'm not joking.
- I might as well just
strip in front of them.
- But did you know there's
a way that you can stop it.
- How?
- By using ExpressVPN goddamit.
They won't even see a
website that you go to.
- [Garnt] ExpressVPN creates a secure,
encrypted tunnel between
your device and the internet.
So people can't peep on
your online activity.
- It's really easy to use.
Just fire up the app and click one button
and you're connected to the
internet in a different country.
- [Joey] Plus it's rated number one by
SeenIt, Wired, The Verge.
Works on your phones,
laptops, even routers.
So everyone who shares
your WiFi can be protected.
- Honestly, I use it all the time.
It's super easy.
It works on phone, laptop.
Like you said, you
literally just start it up,
press one button and it's
like done in seconds.
- I mean you've been using it
to watch the Olympics right?
Right now?
- Yep.
It's super good.
It just works.
- It works.
- It just works.
- I have no complaints.
- Secure your online
activity today by visiting
expressvpn.com/trashtastes.
That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S-V-P-N.com/trashtaste.
And you can get an extra
three months for free.
- ExpressVPN.com/Trashtaste.
Links in the description.
Back to the show.
- I really like, as we
said, "Terraformers."
"Terraformers" is a great action.
- That was a great manga.
- But like the story is
kind of meh at times.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But the action is spot on.
It's so cool.
Actually, we spoke about
"Terraformers" before,
but "Terraformers" is just, it's a manga
which is one of my favorites.
And it has like a ridiculous
amount of chapters.
I think like 400 something I think it has.
- It's like 30..
- It has a lot.
- It's almost 30 volumes, I think.
- Yeah, and it's like,
I think they just started a new arc
when I stopped reading it.
And it felt like it was going
to be the last and biggest arc
and I was like, "Fuck me."
- I think it's already finished.
- Is it finished?
- I think.
- Has it?
- I don't know.
- No way.
- Because I only read up to around like
volume, like, 11 or 12.
- So the concept of "Terraformers",
which dude I was so fucking
sold on this concept,
'cause I was like, that's fucking badass.
- Yeah it's very cool.
- So they sent a mission
to explore the moon.
And when they got there,
there was cockroaches that could just,
they were just ripped like...
- GigaChad.
- GigaChad cockroaches.
- Someone has shot their
fridge into the moon
and it had cockroach on there.
- Yeah, may bad.
Sorry about that.
It's like GigaChad cockroach.
I know we spoken about
"Terraformers" before
in like the third episode or something.
- Yeah it's been a while.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so there's cockroaches on the moon
and turns out they're not
just any normal cockroaches.
They're GigaChad cockroaches
that are like super human beings.
Super smart, but have the
senses of cockroaches.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So this whole team dies that goes there
and you see this right away.
So it's not a spoiler.
So then Earth goes in there
like, "We must do something."
So they go and get warriors or
people they think are worthy
to fight and they inject them
in their DNA with insect DNA.
- [Joey] Yeah insect DNA.
- So each one of them
has insect attributes.
So one of them is like a praying
mantis mixed with a human
and so he can punch really
like lightning fast.
- One of them I think they injected
with like a flea so they can
jump really fucking high.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
And one, this was and average sort,
one of them got the, what is the?
Fuck what's it called?
It's the shrimp that
can like flick at like?
- [Joey] Oh the punching shrimp.
- The mantis shrimp.
- [Garnt] The mantis shrimp.
- The mantis shrimp that can break glass
by flicking the air in front of it.
And I was like, "Oh shit.
I know the mantis shrimp is bad ass."
And so then they send them to the moon
to go and do research
and fight back against-
- Fight the GigaChads.
- And it's so fucking cool
'cause then it turns into
like a political thing
because obviously if
there's shit on the moon,
it's going to be a lot
of countries arguing
about what's going on
there and who did it?
Why was this here?
How many, how many chapters they have?
- [Producer] 22 Volumes.
- 22 volumes?
- Okay.
- It is over or is it still going?
- [Producer] It's 2000.. yeah it's over.
- Oh, it's over?
Okay I need to finish it then.
- I guess this is just the Connor
needs to catch up to manga episode.
- I read it three years ago?
- Yeah.
- And it was still ongoing.
Was it?
When did it end?
- A couple of years ago, right?
- [Producer] 2014.
- No.
- I think it started in 2014, didn't it?
- [Producer] It started in 2011.
- Oh shit.
- Wait when did it finish?
- [Producer] 2014.
- Really?
There's no way I could
have read everything
because when I finished
reading it, it was not done.
- Yeah.
It was still going at that
point, I'm pretty sure.
- Are you sure it's over?
- [Producer] Yeah I double checked.
- Okay.
- Either way you need to catch up on it.
- Either way I need to catch up
and it was such a fun manga.
And if you like "One Punch Man,"
I think you'll love "Terraformers."
- I'm curious.
How did you find "Terraformers?"
- I watched the anime.
- Oh.
Oh my God!
- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you had to go through that.
- I'm so sorry,
what convinced you from
the anime to be like,
"I'll read the manga, maybe the manga."
- Maybe the manga's better.
- From, okay, so "Terraformers"
had an anime adaptation
and it was notorious for
being absolutely dreadful
because what they did
was they made this extremely gory anime
and they were like, "This is great.
Let's just censor everything."
But they did it in the worst fucking way.
They literally just put black dots
and bars across the screen.
So there was some scenes where
you couldn't see anything.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's literally infamous
because I remember when it first-
- Put some screenshots on the screen.
- Because I remember I
read the "Terraformers"
before the anime came
out and I was just like,
"How are they going to adapt this?"
'Cause some of these scenes
are pretty brutal, pretty gory.
- There are brutal yeah.
- And then I saw that,
I think a famous scene as well,
like the cockroach is
holding someone's head
and he's just holding a black dot.
- A black circle.
- Because dude, this I,
I'm still convinced, right,
if this had like a good anime adaptation,
like a solid animation, like
not "One Punch Man" level,
but close to it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Of the action scenes
being done that well,
this would be like fucking top 10 anime.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
And that's why I was looking forward to it
because I remember I got
recommended the manga
from one of my friends who, he was like,
"Dude, you have to fucking read this.
This is amazing."
I read, I was like, "Oh!"
- Because could you imagine
the shock people would get
when they're like, there's a scene right,
where it's very early on so
it's not really a spoiler,
but one of the scenes 'cause all the teams
drop in different locations on the moon.
So you kind of get like play by plays
of where all the different
teams are on the moon.
And one of the scenes
where one team just goes
out of the ship and immediately just,
they see a flash and someone
lost their head already
and it's like, "Holy shit!"
- [Joey] And it was like
right after she was injected
as well so it was like,
"All right, here comes,
Here comes the part where she kicks ass."
And then immediately dies.
- Yeah, yeah.
And it's like, "Oh shit,
that they're stronger."
And it's like,
everything about the show is so hype
and like reading the manga, it's like,
"Okay, how are they
going to build on this?"
And they just keep finding ways
to make it more and more interesting.
It's like, "Holy shit!"
- And the art style is so good.
- It's so good!
- The art is so good!
- The art is so good.
- Like the manga just
never stops kicking off.
It's like permanently, just kicking off.
- It's called really popping off.
- Yeah there's always fights.
And if there's not fights,
there's some like "Game of Thrones"
political shit going on.
And it's like, "All right.
Just because we're on
the moon doesn't mean
that China doesn't hate Russia."
Like there's stuff going on.
And then it's like, it's so it's so good.
Yeah.
And I love how they introduce,
like I love it when shows,
when there's a lot of
characters that is like,
this is the character,
this is where they're from.
This is the height.
This is their ability.
And you're like, "Sick, sick.
Thanks."
Now I can mentally
remember that information.
- Yeah 'cause how I
discovered "Terraformers"
is moving on to the next show
on your list which is "Gantz."
Like I, I literally finished "Gantz"
and I was like, "I need
more shows like 'Gantz.'"
- It's very reminiscent on "Gantz."
- I think it's just like how
brutal and unpredictable,
like unpredictable it is in
terms of who's going to live,
who's going to die.
And I feel like it's, you know,
it's the meme wedge where
if you can't predict
what's going to happen
or who's going to die,
it's like, oh, it's kind of
like the "Game of Thrones."
But like the first time I
actually was like properly shocked
at who lived and who
died was fucking "Gantz."
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Which I don't know if,
how much we can go into
spoilers about "Gantz."
But like, you cannot predict who dies.
- It's insane, it's insane.
- Yeah.
- And the anime was like, it was decent.
It was pretty solid as well.
- [Connor] Yeah I feel like
if you are between the ages
of like, even though you
shouldn't be reading this for 16,
but if you are the age of 16-
- No this is like the perfect...
I think I've watched the
anime when I was 16 years old.
- This is like the most I'm 16.
And I want to be experiencing badass shit.
(guys laugh)
Because, okay,
there's a scene that
happens very early on right.
And this is quite graphic, where,
so I wish I could explain
the premise, right.
So "Gantz", what happens is wait,
how does it very, very start.
- It starts with the two main characters
jumping in front of a train.
- Yeah so-
- Oh yeah that's, oh my God.
That's right.
- So the two characters
die in a train crash
or like they didn't-
- And that scene was fucked as well.
- So they died pretty
brutally in a train crash.
And afterwards they wake up in this room
and this black circle has transported then
to this room along with a lot of-
- It's so fucking iconic.
- Along with other
people who have just died
and the (indistinct)-
- And everyone's wearing a suit, right.
- And everyone's wearing a suit.
They kind of look like they're wearing
like gimp suits or whatever-
- Morph suits.
- Yeah.
And they're told that they
have to go kill this alien.
- Oh wait, no, they don't wear the suits.
They're told to wear the suits.
- Yeah they're told to wear the suits.
- Some people don't
want to wear the suits.
- And it looks, it looks like a fucking-
- It does looks like a gimp suit.
- It does kind of look
like a gimp suit, right.
- And there's just a moment in this anime,
and the manga, it's a slight spoiler,
but not really.
Happens pretty early on.
Where like a girl gets
transported in the room
and he's like a teenage boy
and he's like, "Let's have sex."
And she's like, "Okay."
And they just have sex.
And you see it.
You're like, "Whoa, okay.
What!"
- And they don't do a
"Terraformers" in the anime.
They show it in the anime.
- In the anime there's literally
two sex scenes in the anime.
- Yeah and he just starts
having sex with her
in the fucking hallway of this house.
And it's like, "Whoa, okay.
I haven't experienced
this before in a manga
and its just fucking happening.
All right."
- I don't even think Dojen's
could get into the sex scenes.
- Yeah it was literally a girl being like,
"Do you want to have
sex because we're dead?"
- And he's like, "Yeah, sure."
- Yeah.
- And I remember watching,
literally watching "Gantz,"
when I was about like, yeah, 15, 16.
- It is the most, "I'm 16
and want a badass show."
- And I'm just like,
"Oh my God, they're showing
a sex scene in an anime."
- What do you mean even now
when I, when I read it like last year.
You know, it's one of those shows
that there's nothing quite like it.
Whoa this is really fresh.
Holy Shit.
I haven't experienced anything like this.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it doesn't hold punches, you know?
And the whole aspect is that
they have to kill these demons
that exist in the human world.
- Aliens.
- Yeah aliens.
- Yeah, they say that there's been aliens
that have been living in the human world
and then they have to
like kill them and so-
- And they're worth points.
And they have to get X amount
of points to come back alive.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
Or, you know, there's,
there's different things
that they can do with points.
They can bring people
who have died before,
back to life as well.
The point is that to kill an alien first,
you think it's like an easy thing to do,
but like it's really, really,
fucking difficult to kill these aliens.
And every arc, there's a different alien
that they need to kill
and there's a different-
- It's harder and harder.
- And it gets harder and
harder and progressively
like more and more people die to the point
where you can never really
expect who's going to live
and who's going to die.
- Yeah.
- And I remember like,
I feel like the peak arc was part two,
'cause it's like separated
into three parts.
I think.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I think part two was the best.
Part three had some really,
really good moments.
I feel like there is a
certain climax to "Gantz"
that really like, it really,
it made me really existential.
- Yeah yeah I know what you're on about.
- And without spoiling
too specific details,
when they find the creator of these balls,
that fucking scene just like,
I remember reading the
events of that scene.
And I'm just like, "Oh my God."
- This man did like 10 tabs of LSD.
It's so like give your
gigabrain existentialism
- I mean have you read
anything else Oku Hiro?
- Yeah I've I know he did the-
- "Inuyashiki" was fucked.
- Yeah I've heard.
I know of the other stuff he's done
and it's all fucked from what I've heard.
- Yeah he did it in "Inuyashiki",
the most recent one he did
was this one called "Gigant."
- I've heard of it.
- "Gigant?"
- Yeah "Gigant."
It's like Gigith and Garnt put together.
(guys laughing)
- Is it another, just awful...
- "Gigant" is also just like,
I've started reading it.
It's real-
- Is it finished?
- No, it's still going.
- I can't fucking take this.
I can't take that title seriously.
- It's really fucking good
but it's like, you know,
it's an Oku Hiro manga
because it's just fucked.
- There is a,
there is one scene that I will warn you
is extremely questionable in the show.
And we spoke about this
before in the podcast.
It is extremely questionable.
Just giving you a heads up.
Yeah.
It's a little racist.
It's quite racist.
- Well I mean, "Eyeshield"
has a similar scene.
- Yeah we spoke about this
before on the podcast as well,
but just get heads up.
If you do go into it,
there is like that moment.
It's very yikes in like, "Okay.
All right."
- It's like all right, cool.
- It's, what I love about
"Gantz" and "Terraformers"
it's just, it's pure bat shit insane fun.
It is.
And like, it's,
it's kind of like the edgy
16 year old in you, but like-
- Hundred percent.
But it brings out the 16
year old in you who thinks
like just fighting and death is bad ass.
- But like there's like two
kind of different categories
I put this in, you know,
there's like the edgy 16
year old kind of shows
where it brings that out of you.
And it remembers what you
felt like when you were 16.
And then there's shows like "Elfin Lied"
and "Mirai Nikki"-
- I was about to say "Elfin Lied".
- Yeah, that you watch and I'm just like,
"Damn, why the fuck
did I ever enjoy this?"
- Yeah.
"Gantz" I can look back and
I'm like, "That was good."
- [Garnt] Yeah that was good.
- "Elfin Lied" I look back and I'm like,
"Why was this even remotely popular"
- I was like.
- This show sucks.
- I was like "'Elfin Lied':
10 out of 10 when I was 16 and
now I'm like-
- Was I this easy to trick when I was 16
when I saw blood and tits.
- [Connor] Yeah, because when you were 16,
this is new to you.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] yeah.
- This shit is exciting.
You're like, "Whoa, they can do this."
- It's edgy, it's artistic.
- Yeah.
It's crazy.
- Yeah. I remember a point when
"Elfen Lied" was literally,
when I joined the community,
"Elfen Lied" was considered
like a modern day classic.
- Yeah, yeah.
I remember that.
- I think to a lot of people it still is.
- No!
- Yeah to a lot of people it still do.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- And then someone was like,
"If you thought the anime was good,
read the manga."
'Cause it's like completely different.
And I was like, "All right, bet."
- And it's no different.
- No, it is.
It's actually more fucked in the manga.
But like, you know, 16
year old Asian me was like,
"How could they improve on this?"
And then you read it now.
And I'm like, "All right."
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, I mean,
I think I watched like
"Fullmetal Alchemist" before it
and just going from that
where I was like, "Okay."
- You went from "Fullmetal
Alchemist" to "Elfen Lied?"
- Yeah I was like looking at my monitor
with like with all these
fucking pop-ups everywhere.
Like, "Whoa, what the fuck?
She just cut them up and
with like, ghost arms."
- Yeah, I think that like the next show
after "Elfen Lied" and "Mirai Nikki"
was probably "Akame Ga Kill."
Where...
Well, I remember it got so fucking popular
and I'm just like,
I watched the anime.
- That is peak I am 16 and edgy.
- Yeah, I am 16.
Like I'm 14 and this is deep.
- I am convinced.
Right, okay.
I like "Elfen", I (indistinct).
I like "Akame Ga Kill."
I'm going to say it right now.
I like it, okay.
I don't care people say, I like it.
Fuck you.
I like the anime.
- Wait did you finish it?
- The anime?
- Yeah.
- You still like it?
- I still like it.
- Okay.
You can clown on me all you want.
I liked it.
- That's fine.
That's fine.
You're entitled to your wrong opinion.
- This is good.
I think this will make sense.
It's just how I view it.
- [Joey] Sure.
- POV, you're a "Fairytale" fan.
You're tired of "Fairytale."
You want something a little edgier.
You go immediately to "Akame
Ga Kill" that's, it feels...
Think about it.
It is literally "Fairytale", with fans,
but with way more edge.
Because it feels like
"Fairytale" in many aspects
where it's like, "This
is dumb, dumb shit."
- Why specifically "Fairytale?"
- Because...
People who like "Akame Ga
Kill" are "Fairytale" fans.
- You are right about that.
- It is literally, if you
are a "Fairytale" fan,
I bet you love "Akame Ga Kill."
- You are right a hundred percent.
- Think about it.
Think about it.
- I'd say it's more "Seven Deadly Sins."
- It's all going to be in the same pool.
- "Seven Deadly Sins" I
think is slightly different.
- You think so?
- We need to make a chart of like
what you're likely to
like, based on what shows.
- Can we just get like a corkboard?
- Yeah we do, right.
I think, I think if "Seven
Deadly Sins" is on one end,
it's like "Hunter x Hunter"
is on the other end, I think.
And then what other shonnens
are there that like,
I don't know,
just like fucking "Seven
Deadly Sins" somewhere else.
- To me "Akame Ga Kill" is
just like the generation
that go onto "Seven Deadly
Sins" or "Fairytale."
And then they also have
watch "Mirai Nikki."
And they were like, "What
if we just combine the two?
What if we just combine the two
and then you get 'Akame ga
Kill' and you're like, great.
You require even less
brain cells to enjoy this.
Brilliant."
- I, even though I recognize
the ending was fucking dumb
for "Akame ga Kill," I liked it.
I thought it was fun.
I had a great time watching that.
I'm not afraid to admit that.
- The plot twist.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was just like, "Come the fuck on."
- Yeah, is was come the fuck on.
But I still had a lot of fun.
Like before that, I had a
lot of fun with the show.
I really enjoyed it.
- Yeah.
Admittedly, as much as I
clown on "Akame Ga Kill,"
first like five, six episodes-pretty fun.
This is like brainless fun, but-
- You know what else I read
that I read all of as well?
Was, I just remembered it now.
Sorry, would you have anything else?
- No, no, no.
I was just going to say-
I read all of "Deadman Wonderland."
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Oh that's also I'm 16 and edgy.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- It's just all rushing back now.
- Because, I want it, you know what?
I went on the thing where I was like-
- Yeah because the anime ending sucked.
- Yeah, I was like, I want it.
This was like two years ago, I read it.
I had the feeling, I was
like, "You know what?
I just want to finish an manga to an anime
that didn't get an ending."
And I was like, "Okay,
'Deadman Wonderland.'"
And the manga was definitely better,
but the manga had a shit ending too.
- Yeah. I mean, not as bad as the anime,
but it was still not as, yeah.
- It was still shit.
It was fine.
"Deadman Wonderland"
was very five out of 10.
- Yeah, I think I was exactly the same.
'Cause I finished "Deadman Wonderland."
- I like the anime a lot.
- Yeah, the anime was great
until about episode 10.
And then the last couple of episodes
where they're just like,
"Oh, ran out of budget."
- Yeah, basically.
- And so I was like, "Okay, okay.
I need to see how this ends."
- Yeah. Yeah.
So what did we talk about so far?
- Do we need to talk about "Jojo?"
Do we really need to talk about Jo?
Do you want to talk about "Jojo?"
- Did you have a favorite part?
- To read, seven.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I haven't actually
read your "Jojolion" yet,
but as of the time of recording this,
they just announced that
it's going to end next month.
- Yeah next month.
- I'm probably going to
speed run reading "Jojolion."
- Yeah I-
- So that I can talk
about it when it finishes.
- Still have to read.
I think I'm like one
volume behind right now
and it's pretty fucking good so far.
I'm surprised they're
ending it this soon though
because I'm not going to go into.
- I've heard that it was not too long ago
that we got introduced
to the main villains.
So I'm not going to,
I don't wanna,
I don't want to say anything
because I don't know anything.
That's just what I know.
'Cause everyone was telling
me that it had so much left,
but whatever.
I'm going to, I'm
probably going to read it.
I might make a video about it.
I don't know if I should
on my main channel.
- It's pretty good.
- Maybe I will, maybe I won't.
- I wouldn't say it's as good as-
- I think it would be on brand for you.
- Yeah, it would be on brand for you.
- In my opinion, it's not as
good as like part six or seven,
but it's up there.
It's still pretty good.
It's "Jojo."
- So we'll see how it we'll see how this,
how your feelings will
change when the new-
- Yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
Like the ending of "Jojolion"
might be fucking amazing.
Right.
- Yeah true.
But yeah, "Jojo," I mean-
- I mean, it was the "Jojo" manga
that made you a "Jojo" fan.
Right?
- Yeah.
So it was definitely I
was watching part five
and I wanted more of part five
because it hadn't fully aired.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- We were only like 10 episodes in
and I was really enjoying it.
So I went and picked up the manga.
And I just fucking loved it.
Like I said, it's such a great time.
It's a shame that it's the
English official release
is quite slow.
I think they just finished
part 4 translation.
- Yeah. I mean like-
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Oh geez.
- Like a lot of people
forget that "JoJo" just like,
was this super fucking underground manga?
That only like a select
few people really read
before the anime became a thing.
- In the West.
- Yeah in the West.
And so like, there was just no interest
to translate it officially
until the anime came out.
Now it's weird seeing it
become this like massive,
one of the most biggest anime franchises.
- I made a video on, what was it?
It was like,
I had this series like back in the day,
it's like five years
ago, I had this series
where I would like go into manga
and like kind of find like myths
and like kind of secrets
and stuff like that
and kind of talk about it.
I remember I made a video on,
it was part three "Oingo
Boingo" and there's that like,
you know, the manga that he opens?
- Oh the 9-11?
- The 9-11 thing.
I made a video on that five years ago.
No views.
No views at all.
I was like, "Oh my God."
And that's when I realized I was like,
"Oh no one in the West knows 'Jojo'."
- Yeah.
- At that point.
- I feel like "Jojo" was such a 50/50
on whether it would do well.
I think it just-
- I'm really surprised that it did.
- It just got,
I think it just got lucky with the memes.
- I think so yeah.
- I think it was, it was like,
so perfected for meme
culture that it was like,
so ahead of its time.
And it's really weird.
- Because it wasn't really
meme'd until part three.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The anime came out.
- I guess so.
- I feel like I did not
see anything about it
until part three came out.
And then I saw I never stopped
seeing the "Dio versus
Joejaro" like steam sale memes,
you know.
You'd see a ton of memes
with the "Ora-ora-ora"
and all that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's when it really started
picking up steam I think.
And then it started,
I think the people started realizing
how good the anime adaptation was.
And then part,
I remember it really
kicked off during part four
was airing in the West,
was when it started
really getting some steam.
And then part five, just like insane.
- Blew it out of the water.
- The part five anime
adaptation of "JoJo" really like
sent it into like,
'cause the fucking
"Giorno" theme did numbers
for the meme community
and "Jojo in general."
I mean, how many people got into part,
"JoJo" in general,
from the Giorno's theme?
Because I mean, it's-
- It's like the,
what was the "Undertail" theme?
- "Megalomania?"
- Yeah.
- Yeah that's the one.
- Yeah it's up there with "Megalovania"
in terms of like iconic meme usage.
- It's that of the anime community.
- Because think of like
iconic meme that came out
in the past 10 years,
what have you got there?
Like actual, like iconic,
like super iconic.
"Giorno's theme", "Megalovania."
There's probably some
other than forgetting.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Chug jug.
- I think that wasn't there
wasn't really an explosion
of like, "JoJo" never exploded.
It just slowly crept up in
popularity until you couldn't,
you couldn't like stop-
- It's almost inescapable.
- I just think part five really helped.
Since part five started
airing, it really blew up.
I feel like a noticeable change.
- Yeah, in my opinion,
part five is probably
one of the only parts
where it's actually better in the anime.
- Yeah.
- Part four I think you can go either or.
- Part four is yeah either or.
- Three, two, and one,
hundred percent the manga.
- Manga yeah.
- Yeah, definitely.
- I think part three was
like dragged out too much
in the anime.
- You can speed run it in the manga.
You can be like, "All right, I'm over it."
Obviously don't do that,
but you can through it at a good pace.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But the part three of
the anime is very slow,
which I think "Jojo" in
general is better in manga
also 'cause you have part six and seven,
which are very good,
part seven being, especially
notorious for being amazing.
Part seven is-
- Part seven is amazing.
- Part seven is where I feel like Araqui
really came into his own
and finally made like the
perfect "Jojo" partway.
There was no pacing issues.
- [Garnt] Wow.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I feel like every part of "Jojo"
had some kind of weird pacing
at some point or another.
- Every character is
fun and like memorable.
- Yeah.
Like for example, like part three,
it drags out a bunch.
Part two is very short and sweet.
You don't really get too
much, but it's very nice.
And that's why part two is really-
- I mean Joseph's the
only redeeming factor
about part two in a lot of ways right?
- Yeah Joseph is very...
Yeah, the villain's boring, right.
Part one.
I mean it's notoriously (indistinct).
It's quite boring.
I won't lie.
It has a lot of charm as a "JoJo" fan.
- But at least it's short.
- It's very short.
You can read through it.
Part four Kira,
who is arguably one of
the best villains in Jojo,
isn't there for the first half.
So you kind of get a slice
of life for the first part,
which is fun but it takes a while for it
to kind of find its footing.
- If you're not a fan
of that kind of stuff,
then you can easily like
fall off it and be like,
"Why is this popular?
Why do people like this?"
- Part five is very solid.
I think that Giorno is one
of the weaker "Jojo" bros.
- Jo Bros.
- You know but Bruno
Bucciarati does carry part 5.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- And then part 6, you know, it's good.
It obviously has a bit of
a controversial ending.
- I really like it.
- I like it but some people don't like it.
I can understand why people
wouldn't like it for the,
some parts of part six are a little weak.
But part seven is like from
the start to finish, banger.
Every single character,
banger, like the villains,
even like the side villains are amazing.
- I mean it does have kind of
the least memorable Jojos though.
Johnny.
- Yeah, I dunno.
I feel like-
- Johnny doesn't get good till
like the last quarter, maybe?
- Johnny comes into his own
but I feel like Jono doesn't
really come into his own
at any point.
Sorry if we're going on a
whole thought about "Jojo."
- Watch or read "JoJo."
- Just talk about "JoJo."
- "Jojo" fans being "Jojo" fans.
- Exactly.
- You need to read it.
'Cause then you can experience part seven,
which you should a hundred percent read.
It is amazing.
No, you can't skip to it.
Don't do that.
Because part seven has so many references
to previous parts.
You'd be spoiling it.
Read it all, it's amazing.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- All right, what else?
- "Vinland Saga."
Did you put this on your list
or not or we'll get into it?
- I didn't put this on my list.
Yeah, I almost did.
But then I was like the anime is out.
- "Vinland Saga" gets to go on my list,
one, because its banger,
two, because they spell
a Welsh town correctly.
(guys laugh)
- Yeah.
It's got one of the most
badass like antagonists
in like manga, and he's Welsh.
He's Welsh as well.
Of course I knew you'd love this.
- Let's go lads!
- Represent!
They went to like somewhere,
and I was so glad that they,
I want, I really want it,
'cause I obviously I read it in English.
I really want to see how
they spelled this Welsh town.
Incatacana.
- Incatacana.
Like, because it's like,
it was like a Bruheynyuck or something.
And I was like, "How the
fuck do you, how the,
how on earth do you"-
- I don't remember how
I'm pretty sure I got up to that part,
but I don't remember how they spelled it.
- I really want to see
how they spelled it.
- Oh, that's a funny name.
- Because how on earth do
you put the (throat) sound?
- They probably don't.
- They probably didn't.
- Yeah, they probably did
like (attempt to pronounce).
But honestly, memes aside,
"Vinland Saga" is amazing.
- [Joey] Brilliant, yeah.
- I think even if I had
read more than 10 manga,
it would still be on there.
It is so fucking good.
- And it's on hiatus
and it's still amazing.
- Yeah.
- Is it on hiatus?
- Yeah, isn't it?
- I don't know.
- I feel like it's still-
- I read up to a certain point.
I caught up and then I stopped.
- What is it about like
all these like Sain manga,
the Sain classics, I
would like to call them,
that just eventually go on hiatus.
- The Sain masterpieces
always go on hiatus.
- Yeah Sain masterpieces
Right?
- Man it's just "Vinland
Saga" is just amazing.
And like when you realize
it's a fucking prologue,
the first arc is just a prologue
and yet it's still one
of the best stories.
- Okay, what do you think for,
'cause if you've seen
season one of "Vinland Saga"
you know what the prologue is.
You know what the main beginning arc is.
What do you think of the Farmland Arc?
- I really like the Farmland Arc.
- I'm excited to see the reaction
on the anime only viewers
to the Farmland Arc.
- Okay so we won't talk too much about it.
Don't want to spoil it, but it
changes the pace drastically.
- Yeah.
- Okay. So if you think
that if you're go into season two
thinking that it's going
to be in the same vein
as season one, you're
going to be disappointed.
- The way I find a feel about it, right?
Is that "Berserk" and "Vinland Saga",
they have a crossroads
and they both went different ways with it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Whereas, you know, for
example, Guts, right.
Never stops becoming violent.
Guts arguably becomes
more violent every time.
And you know,
"Vinland Saga" tries to make a character
that maybe feels a little
bit more guilty about that.
And so that's what was
really interesting for me
is that they weren't just like,
"Okay, this guy's good at killing."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's what he does now.
[Joey] Yeah.
- He just keeps killing.
It's like, no, he
actively, like, he matures.
He doesn't want to keep doing that.
And that's what's so interesting about it.
And really recommend reading it.
It is just amazing.
- It like a huge artistic
risk he took with that-
- [Connor] Oh Yeah.
- And it paid off.
- It's like his, the worst thing he did
was making the prologue so fucking good.
Like imagine that being the
worst thing you could do.
You made it so fucking good
that people expected
you to keep doing that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's like, he keeps doing it,
but in a completely
different type of story.
Because it's like "Vinland
Saga" is fucking incredible,
but like the prologue is so different
than the rest of the story
that if you come into it
with the same expectations,
you're going to just get whiplash.
You're going to be like,
"Where's the action?
Where's the killing?
Where's the violence?
There was so much of this in season one."
And now we're just like,
well, once you've realized
that the story was never about that,
that the story was all about-
- They were building it up the whole time.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
When you realize that everything
that his father said at the beginning
was what the story was meant to be about
from the get-go and everything else
was just like, a bigger tangent
than anything that we've ever gone on.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You know, and that was..
Yeah, season one was just a tangent.
- But it's so true to life
because even if your dad told you shit
you wouldn't fucking listen to him.
But then you'll realize
when you were an adult,
he was right all along.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Exactly.
- That's why and it's genius.
- I'm sorry I went against you father.
You were right.
- It's so good because it's so like,
even though the situation
is obviously crazy,
but even though it's
not that unbelievable,
because you know, it's set on
like a real part of history, you know?
And it builds characters
in such a compelling way
that is so realistic and
every single character
in this show, you're like, "I
believe that could be a dude."
You know, I believe that
I see parallels to myself
in some of these characters
that are uncomfortable
and that's what I loved about it.
It was so good.
And it presented war in a horrific way.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- As war should be.
And so if you haven't
please do yourself a solid
and read "Vinland Saga."
It is amazing.
And I'm so excited.
- If you like Vikings it's-
- If you like Vikings.
Just at least read it for Askeladd
or at least watch the anime for Askeladd.
- Welsh represent.
- Because he is honestly like,
I think one of my favorite characters.
- Oh yeah in anime.
- In the medium.
- Straight up.
And also, I mean,
I'm very excited for the
reaction to anime fans,
anime-only fans to the-
- Season two.
- [Connor] Yeah season two.
- Farmland arc.
- To be like hey when does stuff happen?
- So how long are they going
to stay on this farm for?
- Yeah it goes from like
"Doom" to "Runescape"
in like one chapter.
- It's like "Doom" to "Farmville"-
- It's like "Stardew Valley"
or something like that.
- I guess that's spoilers enough right?
- I mean "Berserk"
we've literally just
talked about "Berserk."
It's a classic for a reason.
- I've spoken about "Claymore" before.
"Claymore" again is a very similar
to I guess "Berserk" in some ways.
- Yeah, it's dark fantasy right?
- Would you say you enjoyed it enough
that if you had read more manga,
you think it would still be in your-
- I don't think it would be on here
if I'd read some other big
names that I know I would enjoy.
I think it's got a banger first half.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then loses its steam.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, there's some stories
where you're reading the manga
and you're like this
motherfucker planned everything-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like a blueprint.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- He knew exactly what
was going to happen.
And he knew exactly where this was going.
Whereas with "Claymore"
I feel like they would,
he was just like,
they were just writing
it and he had a core idea
and he just didn't
or they, I don't know
if it's a guy or a girl.
They just didn't really know
how they wanted to finish it.
But that's, there's the,
I believe George R.R.
Martin talks about this.
There's two ways of writing stories
and there's the architect
and the something to do
with like growing plants or something.
One likes to design
everything like a building.
You have every single
aspect, like out perfectly.
And the other it's like a greenhouse,
you just kind of grow
things, see where it goes.
See what goes with it.
I definitely feel like
that is a riskier way
of doing stories but also can lead
to some super interesting results.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I feel like "Claymore"
just kind of lost itself partway through.
- And I feel like the
architect like type is like
the downside to it is like
you could build too much
and then you kind of have to like,
"Oh shit, I have to pick up
all these pieces somewhere."
- Yeah, you have so much
where maybe you build
too much of the world
which sometimes is a bad thing.
- I mean you call pull a Togashi right.
And just like "Hunter x Hunter"
introduce like 17,000 things.
- It's just harder to maintain as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like you put more bricks down
and you put more bricks down.
Then you forget the foundations you laid,
then you start building a chimney
where you've already
built like a fireplace
on the other side.
It doesn't make like any sense sometimes.
- Exactly, I'm running out of bricks.
I don't have much time left my back hurts.
I can't draw shit.
I should've thought about this, that-
- Or you could just be like Araqui
and just be like,
"I'm just going to plant the
seed here and see how it goes."
- Which is what I love about that he...
That is the perfect example
of that kind of writer.
Araqui literally just gives you ideas
and then he just keeps expanding on it.
And you can tell you some idea
of where he wants it to go,
but you can tell also there's so many-
- It's not completely planned out.
- You can tell there's so many
moments where he just like,
and he even says it himself, right.
When he just decides to do things because-
- He doesn't remember
half the shit he wrote.
- It's such a fun way.
And it leads to such fun writing.
- Yeah, a hundred percent.
- But yeah, "Claymore,"
although an amazing concept,
amazing first half.
Yeah, definitely loses steam.
- [Joey] And the art is so good.
- [Garnt] Yeah the art is
up there as one of the best.
- [Connor] Fucking amazing bro.
Fucking love that shit.
- What is it about dark fantasy
where just the art is
just always a banger?
- I don't know.
It's like a rite of passage, right?
Oh, you want to write a dark fantasy?
Show me your drawings.
- You better have godly art.
- And for some reason I'm a simple man.
I like rankings.
So whenever there's characters
and they have ranks and like-
- Spoken like a true gamer.
- They're clearly defined as
this is "number one strong,"
this is "number two strong."
I don't know why I love that but-
- Because you're a gamer.
- Yeah because it's like-
- I feel like there's
just something embedded
into like humans that just like ranking.
- We love ranking things and I loved it...
And then the story aspect of "number seven
could actually be stronger
than number two in some ways."
And that's super interesting.
- I can see you why you
like "One Punch Man."
- Yeah "One Punch"...
I love the hero rating
system of "One Punch Man."
I think it leads to such
interesting, like characters,
in really strange ways.
Like yeah, I love the
Bicycle Man in there.
- Yeah.
- I mean that's just part
of like Shonen anime, right?
We need to rank people
'cause people like ranks.
The people like power.
- I love it.
- [Garnt] What are the, what
are the Shonen Youtubers
going to make videos about
if we can't fucking rank.
- Exactly, right?
- In Japanese companies,
you get ranked on your
performance with a ranking grade.
- It's like, "I wanna be number one."
- Yeah so like, it's
like they love doing it.
It's everything needs to be ranked here.
(Joey laughs)
- I'm going to make a bidet rank.
- What I love is how
everyone's just found out
like power ranking things.
Just like people just,
you could power rank
the most mundane things.
- This is why we have tier lists Garnt.
- This is why tier
lists is a thing, right?
- This is literally why tier lists exist.
- Yeah it's literally just power rankings.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then obviously "Eyeshield 21"
which is...
I've watched "Kuroko no Basket."
I've watched "Yowamushi Pedal."
What other sports anime are famous?
- "Haikyuu."
- I've watched "Haikyuu."
- "Slam Dunk."
- I haven't read "Slam Dunk."
I'm going to read "Slam Dunk."
- [Joey] Okay.
- But so far, this is my
favorite sports story.
- Oh yeah, it's awesome.
- And again, like the visual-
- This single handedly got
me into American football.
- I still don't know the rules fully,
but I had a fun time.
- I mean, it's very
deviated from real life.
- It is.
I'm like I'm watching
real American football
and I'm just like,
where are the metaphors?
Where?
- I'm not going to lie.
Like I was like, you
know, when I read this,
cause I was like in the
prime of my childhood
when this was in Shonen Jump, right.
So everyone like everyone was
trying to like do rodeo drives
and like devil back
ghosts and shit like that.
- Yeah where's the devil back ghost?
- It's just a great fucking manga man.
It's so good.
- It's good.
- I'd be lying if I said, I
didn't practice rodeo driving.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I'm like, this is the one move
that is probably like the most feasible.
- If I ever throw a football ever again,
you bet I'm going to like picture
a fucking angel behind me.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- There's a panel where like,
he throws this ball
and it's like this amazing
artwork of like this angel.
It's like the angel throw or something.
I don't remember what it was.
This panel, it's like a spread,
and it's fucking beautiful.
And it's just, oh, so good.
- I think some of the best
is where you see the
battle of the metaphors.
And I think it just makes the,
it makes the sports
scene so much more hype.
'Cause I can't remember the exact,
because it's been years and years
but I remember like very vividly
just someone kicking a ball
and it just like,
it kicked with like so
much force or something
that it like penetrates
something that's...
Fuck, I'm speaking...
What was like the second to last match?
- The second to last match
was against the best school.
And they were like the
best school in Japan
because that's was probably
the highlight of it.
And then afterwards they fight America.
(Garnt laughs)
- That's right.
- And that kind of sucked.
But yeah, they go against
like the best players,
the real number seven.
- The real number, the real-
- 21, 21.
"Eyeshield 21," fucking hell.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- "EyeShield 21."
- Real EyeShield 21.
- The real EyeShield 21.
- What was the number?
- Sorry then if that's spoilers,
that might be spoiler actually.
(indistinct) spoiler warning.
Put this before.
Yeah.
- Yeah, it's brilliant.
- Yeah, they face the
the real EyeSheild 21.
- All right.
- And as they all have interesting
powers that is literally,
it's literally "Kuroko
no Basket" on the field.
- I think the guy who wrote "Eyeshield 21"
went on to do another Shonen Jump manga.
- "Dr. Stone?"
- Yeah. He wrote "Dr. Stone."
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- That's right.
- Yeah, I remember that.
Very good storyteller.
- Very different as well.
- Yeah I like that.
All these, all these I would recommend.
- Honestly.
All of these are very, very solid shows.
I mean, it's like,
it kind of gives off the
vibe of just like, yeah.
I've only read my manga,
which you kind of have.
- At you've read nine great manga.
- You've read like nine great manga.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- [Joey] Good taste.
- [Garnt] Assuming the bottom left
is replaced with "Terraformers."
- [Connor] It's amazing.
Yeah and this one you can read on Book...
or listen to on Book Walker.
- I guess it's kind of good you went first
because I guess you can listen
to some of mine and Joey's recommendations
or like some of our favorite manga.
I mean, I'm not going to
say I recommend everyone
that's on my three-by-three.
- Yeah, me neither.
(guys laugh)
- But there are definitely
some recommendations
that I think everyone should
read on my three-by-three.
So shall we move on to who's next?
- This episode is
sponsored by Book Walker.
- What does daddy Book
Walker have for us today?
- Oh I'll tell you what a daddy has.
Daddy added two new titles
to their exclusive catalog.
Did you know?
- Two brand new exclusives.
- That's the right baby?
And you won't believe it.
One of them is a full color volume
of "Why The Hell Are You Here Teacher."
- Wow!
I couldn't possibly miss out
on the student teacher
action in full color.
- Joey, what is this about?
- Well, I'll tell.
- "Why the Hell are you Here, Teacher"
is a lewd manga series depicting
the awkward relationships
between students and their teachers
who keep getting into awkwardly
embarrassing situations,
inevitably developing an interest
for each other by exploring the appeals
of a grown woman's body.
Did you get all of that?
- Now that sounds spicy.
- The second title they've
brought to us today
is a brand new series called
"She's Adopted a High School Boy."
- Am I dreaming, two
MILF manga in one day?
- I know how excited you
are about that Connor.
- Indeed "She's Adopted a High School Boy"
brings a wholesome story
of a high school student
and the lady living next door to him
who decides to mysteriously adopt him
after he's left behind by his parents
with a mountain of debt.
- Now I want to know more.
- Right!
Then what are you waiting for?
Right now until the end of August,
you can get up to 50% off
all of these titles on Book Walker,
plus you can get 15% coin
back on all eligible titles
in their exclusive fair promotion.
- [Joey] Also if you're
a digital collector,
you'll be happy to find
that purchasing volume one
of the eBooks included in this promotion
will also come with brand
new bookshelf cover images
for your collection.
Did you get all of that?
- Oh wow.
- No I didn't
- [Connor] But guys, don't forget
to follow Book Walker
on Twitter @Book Walker_GL
for the latest information
on new manga titles
and special promotions.
- Thank you Daddy Book Walker.
- Back to the episode.
- Next manga three-by-three.
And we have beer.
- Yeah we have beer.
- This just appeared.
- Cheers boys.
- [All] Cheers.
- It's been a very civilized
three-by-three so far,
but I mean what, what can
we complain about this?
Honestly.
- Normy.
- Yeah.
- Is it normy though?
- Kinda, I'd say it's pretty normy.
- I don't know I man-
- Listen, ain't nothing wrong
with a bit of boys' love.
- [Garnt] That's all right.
- That's as normy as it gets.
- Who's next?
- Which of you wants to go next?
- I don't mind going next.
- You don't want to go next?
- Let's see what Joey has to say then.
- And this might be, oh no okay.
- [Joey] Why is that so tiny?
- Hold on while we unfold.
- Joey.
- Oh it's me.
- Oh, okay.
- I actually thought this was Garnt.
I could have sworn I folded Garnt's tiny.
This is not fixed, I just...
I'm just saying.
Put Joey's on the screen.
- You exposing us Connor.
You're exposing us.
Scripted.
- This is Joey too.
(Garnt laughs)
- It was destiny.
- There is two Joey's.
That was not me.
I swear we did not...
When I asked who wanted to go next.
That was not fixed.
- This is like the Google
when people search up, "What
is Gigert's real name?"
- [All] Joey.
(all laugh)
- All right put Joey's up.
- Put mine up.
- It was rigged, but whatever,
we'll have Joey's up next, I guess.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
- [Connor] Do I know all of these?
Okay let me try and guess this.
All right so "Berserk."
- [Joey] Obviously.
- [Connor] Obviously you put
"JoJo" part six specifically.
- Yeah I like part six specifically.
- "Yu Yu Hakusho."
- Do you know this one?
- Is that Misa from "Death Note" is that-
- Oh fuck, I-
- Do you recognize?
- I kind of recognize this.
- Wait isn't it,
it's the Assassins thing?
- Assassins thing?
- No, that's "Hitman Reborn."
- No, no, no.
- No this is, this was a fucking-
- Wait wait!
- It's a Shonen.
- It's Shonen Jump.
- Yeah.
- "Black Cat."
- It's "Black Cat."
- I've seen the anime "Black Cat."
- Yes.
- Very good.
- Is the manga good?
- Yeah it's fucking awesome.
- But why did the enemy suck dick?
- I don't know.
I didn't watch the anime.
- What the anime was-
- It's a manga tier list.
Not tier list, three-by-three.
- This is a manga three-by-three.
- I had see this.
I was like I've seen this boy with the X.
Triple three Vin-Diesel.
- That's Train.
- All right so this one-
- I forgot his name was Train.
- Yeah it's Train.
(Garnt laughs)
- This is the "Line Rider," right?
That many clip.
- Yeah "Line Rider."
- Wait, what is this?
I don't know this one.
- That's "Oyasumi Punpun."
- Ahhh.
- Of course I knew that
was going to be on there.
- That doesn't look depressing.
- It's hella depressing.
- This doesn't look depressing.
- He's the main character.
- Yeah.
- He's the main character
and everyone else is a
normally drawn character.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- And then-
- Yeah, "Slam Dunk."
[Garnt] And then "Slam Dunk."
"Beastars."
- [Connor] "To Love Ru."
You bought the whole collection
of "To Love Ru" recently.
Right?
- Yeah, accidentally.
(everyone laughs)
- You want to explain the story?
- Okay.
So I got "scammed", quote unquote.
So I bought all the volumes of "Bobobo,"
which was one that I thought
about putting up here.
But it was only volume
one and four though.
So basically I opened up
volume one and it was,
I bought it second hand.
So I was like, "Okay it
was whatever it's cheap.
So it was whatever."
And I was like, "All right, cool.
I'm going to relive my childhood."
Open up volume one of "Bobobo",
it's volume three of "To Love Ru."
(guys laughing)
They just literally replaced the cover.
I got scammed.
- [Woman] You got bamboozled.
- [Joey] They literally just
put the cover of "Bobobo"
on the front of this but it's
volume 3 of "To Love Ru."
- Do you reckon they did it
on purpose or on accident?
- I reckon it's by accident.
I was like, "Wait, don't tell me
all of these are To Love Ru."
Luckily they weren't.
For some reason volume 1 and 4 was.
- So, so it's probably just, you know,
you know when you like
take a DVD out to watch it
and you have to put the
DVD in the DVD player
back in the box,
and then you forget that you've just like-
- Who the fuck replaces a cover though?
- Yeah but, I was going to say.
- I was going to say,
"How does that happen?"
- That analogy would be fantastic
if manga were interchangeable things.
- It was more like, you know, like-
- Book in brain.
- It was more like the
"Bobobo" set was owned
by like a teenager. And it was like, well,
"I need to hide the
degenerative shit from my mom.
I'm going to put the 'Bobobo' cover."
- Oh my God that was totally it wasn't it?
That was totally it.
- That could be it.
- Like they'll never know.
My mom will never know
I have "To Love Ru."
- My mom will never know.
- She'll just think it's "Bobobo."
- Some kids jacked off to
your "Bobobo" volume 1.
- Time to throw that out?
- Is this "Junji Ito?"
- So that's "Uzumaki."
- Ahh.
- Yeah, I still-
- As this, I'll be
surprised if you know it,
"Ichigo 100%."
- Oh it's "Ichigo 100."
- I've heard of this.
- I have not read it or watched it.
- Okay, so which one would
you like to know first?
Obviously we,
I think we can get rid
of a "Berserk" and "Jojo"
'cause we already talked about that.
- Already talked about that.
- So "YuYu Hakusho" and
not "Hunter x Hunter"?
- Okay, I'm probably
going to get destroyed.
- Okay.
- Haven't read "Hunter x Hunter" yet.
- Whoa.
(Garnt laughs)
- Whoa, I can't believe you haven't-
- Wait, wait, wait.
- I haven't done that but-
- You haven't read-
- The reason why-
- Have you watched it?
- Nope.
(guys laugh)
- Okay well I've watched
it and it's amazing.
- Yeah, the only reason why I-
- The biggest Tohashi simp
hasn't read "Hunter x Hunter."
- I know so much about "Hunter x Hunter"
just from outside information.
But I haven't actually
read it or watched it.
I own all the volumes right now.
- [Connor] I think it's the-
- It's sitting there
waiting for a rainy day.
- I think it's safe to say this:
it's the best Shonen anime.
- I feel like-
- A lot of people say that.
- I feel like I've been lied to.
Because the amount of times we
talk about "Hunter x Hunter"
and me and Connor have
just like been talking
about the Dark Continent.
I had just-
- We always meme like
Netro getting hyped up.
- I just always assumed
that Joey was just like-
- What the fuck?
- Literally all the information I know
is because people around
me don't stop talking
about "Hunter x Hunter."
- What the...
That is not okay.
You need to go watch it, what the fuck?
Or read it.
The anime is amazing.
- I never said I read it or watched it.
- I just assumed the anime man
had watched "Hunter x Hunter."
- I feel like this has just
been a game of "Among Us" now.
- Yeah, yeah.
He's a fucking imposter.
- We've exposed the imposter.
- I should've known the
guy with anime is his name
was a fucking imposter.
- There's an imposter among us right now.
- Again, I know so much
about "Hunter x Hunter."
I could probably like give you
the outline of how it goes,
but I don't know the details.
- What are the names of the arcs?
- I want to go back to every
clip now that we talked about-
- I know like Dark Continent
arc, Chimera Ant arc,
all of those.
The Hunter Exam arc and all that.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
I know them.
Again because I hear it from every body.
- You have to watch it.
- What is this?
- Again, I know I will love it.
- Yeah.
- Of course I will.
I fucking love Togashi stuff.
"Yu Yu Hokusho" I fucking grew up with.
- Wait, what's holding you back?
What's holding you back?
- I don't know. It's just-
- Come on, what are you waiting for?
- It's just one of those
shows I haven't started yet.
- What I want to know is
how we've just found out
about this, despite the
fact that we've talked
about "Hunter x Hunter" so
many times on the podcast.
- Is this publicly known?
Is this widely available information?
- Yeah.
- You've like been a
part of the conversation.
I swear to God.
I don't know, we're going to
have to like rewind every clip
where we've talked
about "Hunter x Hunter."
- I've said it on streams multiple times.
I've never read or watched it.
- I can't be there for the
whole three hours Joey.
You know, I mean.
- Yeah like, again, I know so
much about "Hunter x Hunter"
and I know I'm going to like it.
That's why I'm not in a
rush to read it or watch it.
'Cause I know I'm going to like it.
- Me and "Fullmetal Alchemist."
I get it.
- It's like of course, it's like-
- We've just found Joey's
"Fullmetal Alchemist."
- It's like it's Togashi,
I already love Togashi-
- It's right up your street though.
It's just-
- I know.
And again, I know it's going to be good
'cause I love Togashi.
Like "Yu Yu Hakusho" is fucking amazing.
I don't know.
(Connor burps)
- Don't read it, watch the anime.
The anime is-
- Really?
- The anime is better.
Do you agree?
- Yeah.
- Because I've heard both
sides of the argument.
- [Connor] Listen.
- What's the other side of the argument?
- The other side is that the manga is good
because Togoshi is good.
- I mean that's...
So it's so it's basically just like
a preference in medium then, right?
- Pretty much, yeah.
- I mean, yeah-
- I'm mean I'm probably
going to watch and read both,
to be honest, it's just a
matter of which one to do first.
- Yeah I mean "Hunter x
Hunter" is just prime Madhouse.
And Madhouse haven't been at their prime
for like a long time I think.
- Yeah.
And the manga also looks
like napkin drawings
a lot of the time.
- Not if you buy the volumes.
- No, not in the beginning.
- The volumes?
- The volumes are fixed as well.
- Oh so they fixed it?
- In the Shonen Jump
volumes, the magazines,
it looks like shit.
But then he redraws it
for the actual volumes.
- I finished the anime and
then carried on reading.
And I was like, "Am I reading
like One Web comic right now?
Like, what is this?"
- It was about that
drawing style wasn't it.
- Honestly it's it's yeah.
But I...
Yeah wow.
- But then he takes the time
to actually redraw everything
properly for the actual books.
So the books look fucking amazing.
- I guess that makes sense.
But also kind of sad if you're
a big "Hunter x Hunter" fan
who waits and then you have
to go back and read it.
But maybe they like that.
- If you read it weekly,
then you'll probably yeah-
- Maybe they like that-
- Read it weekly Lamau.
- When it was serialized weekly.
- So that's your favorite
Shonen Jump title of all time?
- Well, I mean, here's the thing,
a lot of these are Shonen Jump.
- I kind of realized that what's like.
What's "Black Cat" doing there?
- "Yu Yu Hakusho",
"Black Cat", "Slam Dunk",
"Ichigo 100%", "Jojo", it's all Jump.
- Let's talk about "Yu Yu Hakusho"
because I haven't watched,
I think I mentioned on
the podcast one time
I tried to start it and
then I just couldn't.
I couldn't stand the audio on the-
I don't know it was dub or what?
- Oh so you watched the anime?
- I watched five minutes.
I was like, "Oh I can't take this."
- So "Yu Yu Hakusho", it does like a,
what I like to call, a reborn.
Basically it starts off as a
comedy, ends up as an action.
- [Connor] Right.
- Right.
- Same thing with "Dragon ball", right?
Like "Dragon Ball" started off as a comedy
and then Z came along
and it became the action
that it's known for.
So like "Yu Yu Hakusho",
the first couple of arcs,
like when Yuske, the main character dies,
like it's kind of like a slice of life-
- Yeah that's how is starts right.
That's not a spoiler.
- Literally first panel
Yuske, our main character,
gets hit by a car and dies.
- [Garnt] This was before
Isakai was the thing.
He didn't go to another world.
He just-
- He just died.
- He became a ghost.
- I know a lot about "Yu Yu Hakusho"
without ever of watching it.
- Yeah right.
- I know a lot of, I know the bad guy.
I know there's an epic fight with one guy.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I know who it is.
And then yeah-
(Joey laughs)
- Because you know the
Tournament arc, right?
- I know the Tournament arc.
- He literally just described
literally every Shonen anime of all time.
I know the bad guy.
I know there's an epic
fight with the bad guy.
- I know what the bad guy-
- You literally could've
fucking described "JoJo."
- I know what he looks like.
I know who it's going to be.
- The "GigaChad" right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- What's his name?
- I don't know, GigaChad.
(guys laughing)
"GigaChado."
- That's Toguro.
Toguro.
- Toguro that's it.
- I don't think he's even
the best villain of the arc.
- He looks like the, you know,
if you watch "Fairly OddParents."
- Crimson Chin?
- He looks like yeah you know like...
Have you watched "Fairly OddParents?"
- Oh the buff fairy right?
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah he looks like the buff fairy
from "Fairly OddParents."
- I have not seen "Fairly OddParents."
- Let me pull it up.
Let me pull it up.
- Oh my God.
- It does right.
That's like Toguro like 0%
looks like the buff fairy
from "Fairly OddParents."
(everyone laugh)
- Oh my God.
- He looks spot on.
Every time I see the bad
guy from "Yu Yu Hakusho"
I just see that guy.
- Really going to do my
boy Taguro like that.
- Because he has the muscles,
but like the weird neck
and it's literally like
"The Fairly OddParents."
(everyone laughs)
He looks exactly like that.
- Oh my God.
- Put up the picture.
- You literally just ruined one of the-
- Put up the picture of the villain.
Like best villains in all of Shonen anime.
- I can't believe Togashi
copied off "Fairly OddParents."
- Yeah I can't believe they
did him dirty like that.
Like probably Nickelodeon got plagiarized.
- Oh my God.
(everyone laughs)
- It's the same.
It looks the same.
- Good old Togoru.
- All right. So like,
so have you ever seen the
anime of "Yu Yu Hakusho"?
- I have.
- Oh, good.
- All of it?
- Not, not a fan.
Not a fan
- Not a fan?
- It's, I dunno.
It's bittersweet, right?
Because it's like,
same thing with "Black
Cat" where it's like,
I love the manga so much.
- Yeah.
- That like, it wasn't
like the perfect adaptation
that I wanted.
Like, it was good, but it's like,
I'd rather just reread the manga.
- Well, what was missing
to make it the perfect
adaptation as someone who's like,
I haven't read the manga
of "Yu Yu Hakusho."
I've only seen the anime.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, did you like the anime?
- I fucking loved the anime.
- Well you'd fucking
love the manga even more.
- Okay, but like is there
anything I can get from the manga
that I couldn't have already
gotten from the anime?
Or just rewatch the anime?
'Cause I thought the anime
was like a really good adaptation,
especially for its time.
- Yeah
- Like "Records of Ragnorak."
(everyone laughs)
- It was better than that.
- That's solid animation, you know?
I mean, I dunno, like I
think this might just be like
the whole thing was like
how manga art styles
I feel age better than
animation in a lot of aspects.
- [Connor] Yeah I-
- [Joey] In my eyes.
- [Connor] "Demon Slayer" begs to differ.
- You think so?
- Like "Demons Slayer" in
the manga just looks terrible
compared to the anime.
- Well I mean that's
because like the animations
for the character designs
change differently, right?
But like in the anime
adaptation of "Yu Yu Hakusho"
they did a pretty good
job of like readapting,
like, Togashi's art style, I feel.
- I haven't read it, but from
what I've just seen of it,
it looks one-to-one to me.
I don't know if that's-
- [Joey] You think so?
- Just a glance.
That's like a person who should-
- I don't know, I feel-
- Glanced at both.
- I sometimes look at clips of
the anime of "Yu Yu Hakusho"
and I'm like, "Something about
this hasn't aged as well."
- But like 80's...
What was it 90's?
- Do you-
- Yeah it's 90's.
- Like the 90's animation is,
some of it hasn't aged
very well because it was-
- Yeah, I mean some of it's
like very janky limited animation.
This is like a 90's anime.
But like, they still had like when,
during the big fights
there were still like
those Sakaga moments.
- Absolutely.
- Like those have aged wonderfully.
- I mean I honestly think at this point,
it's just like a personal
preference to me.
Like the same thing
with "Slam Dunk" right?
It's like "Slam Dunk" for me
like I watched the anime as well,
a fucking banger of an
anime, but it's like,
I just personally prefer
the manga to be honest.
- I actually have like huge problems
with the "Slam Dunk" anime.
I think that's aged horribly.
- [Joey] Really?
- I've heard the "Slam
Dunk" anime isn't very good.
- And that's because-
- Might be a nostalgia factor too.
- Yeah it probably is nostalgia factor.
'Cause I watched it in
university and I was just like,
"Man, this is a,
it's a really slow sports anime."
My fucking God,
it literally like take
10 episodes or something.
- It's like 120 episodes.
- I do think sports
anime, sorry sports shows,
sorry just sports properties in general,
almost better in manga normally.
Like just because of pacing.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think that that's true
like 10 years ago or 20 years ago now
because like "Slam Dunk", "EyeShield",
I would like recommend the manga
way over the anime because-
- Yeah I watched an episode
of EyeShield and I couldn't-
- That's why for me like both "Slam Dunk"
and "Yu Yu Hakusho" are in
my manga three-by-three,
not my anime three-by-three.
Like I much prefer the manga.
- Yeah because like, I
feel like old sports anime,
they had horrible pacing,
but like shows like "Haikyuu", "Kuroko"-
- Actually "Yowamushi Pedal"
I really enjoyed the anime.
- Yeah, "Yowamush Pedal." Like they,
I think within the past, like
new generation of sports,
I mean they really fixed
their pacing issues
to the point where if a match
last more than three episodes,
then it's like a super,
super important match.
Have you seen "Haikyuu"?
- I've watched the first two seasons.
- Okay.
So season three is like one single match.
It's like 10 episodes.
- Yeah I've heard that yeah.
- When I saw that, I was like,
"Here we fucking go again.
Another like "Dragonball
Z"-esque fight scene
in a sports anime.
But like that match was so fucking intense
that it needed 10 episodes.
And then like,
it was just what it...
It was not stretched out at all.
And that was like, to me,
like the highlight of
"Haikyuu" so far of the anime.
- I enjoyed "Koroko no Basket",
I thought that I enjoyed the
pacing on that even if it-
- [Garnt] Yeah, because-
- It was very quite fast really.
- Yeah, I think it was
like actually good pacing.
'Cause it was like never
more than three episodes.
Because how many times like,
I can only be invested in
one match for like so long,
you know?
There's only so much that
can happen in a single match.
- Kuroko was really good at
building up the bullshit,
I think.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Or like-
- What do you mean?
- You know, they weren't rushing too much
into like the powers,
like they were pretty sparingly
adding them in, I felt.
And then I didn't watch the
movie, but everything else-
- The movie was (indistinct).
- Everything past the main
run of the, what is it?
Three seasons?
Two Seasons?
- Three seasons.
- Three.
- After the, how many is that 50 episodes?
- Something like that, I guess.
- Over 50 episodes, yeah.
- It's where they beat the...
Does it end?
It doesn't matter.
But the point was that I found
that out after like that,
that was like not really invested anymore.
- It's such a shame for me.
'Cause like I didn't
watch all of "Kuroko."
Like, but from what I did
see, I really enjoyed it,
but it sucks because
for me now "Slam Dunk"
is just like forever just
ruined basketball anime-
- I wonder if I will read "Slam Dunk"
and I'll feel like I can't enjoy this,
Kuroko is better,
or if I'll feel that like-
- It's definitely been both cases.
So like I've recommended
"Slam Dunk" to people
who first read "Kuroko"
and they were like,
"Ah, it's not as good."
'Cause they're just used
to the "Kuroko" format.
Because unlike "Kuroko",
"Slam Dunk" doesn't have
any like super powers.
It is like the most-
- It's just very realistic.
- Bare bones raw.
- So it's like an NBA Jam versus NBA 2K?
- Yeah, yeah, pretty much.
- Basically.
- Pretty much.
- Yeah. It kind of like
it kind of like takes the fact that
it is probably one of the
most realistic adaptations
of sports in manga.
- But it still makes it just as exciting.
- But it does it in the most
like cinematic, like fuck yeah,
type of way.
And I mean like, you know,
in the case of "Slam Dunk",
like when that first came out in Japan,
it created a fucking cultural phenomenon.
- Every time I have an old taxi man here
and he asks me if I liked anime
or whatever, I'll be like,
"Yeah, I like anime."
And then he's like, "Oh,
do you like Slam Dunk?"
- [Joey] Yeah.
- They always ask me.
If they're in their like forties plus,
they always ask me if I like "Slam Dunk."
- Yeah it was like a cultural
phenomenon here in Japan.
Wasn't it when it came out.
- I think the year that it came out,
I think I read something like
of all like middle schools
and high schools in Japan,
the attendance of basketball
clubs raised by 600%.
- Well basketball's a huge
sport in Japan as well.
- Yeah but it wasn't...
But it got big because of "Slam Dunk."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean it was that good.
I mean, in my opinion, "Slam Dunk",
the final chapter of "Slam Dunk"
is still one of the
most beautiful chapters
in all of manga in mind.
- Yeah I mean he had balls
to just put zero dialogue.
- The entire last chapter
has zero dialogue.
- I'll get there one day.
- And it just ends.
And it is the most cinematic
final chapter of manga ever.
In my opinion.
But I mean like, yeah.
So I mean, obviously that's great.
- So "Black Cat."
- All right so "Black Cat" for me-
- Walk me through it.
- Okay, so you know how my character,
like my avatar on YouTube,
has that cat mask?
- Yeah.
- Oh so that came from "Black Cat?"
- That came from "Black Cat."
- Oh my God, okay.
- So, Yabuki Kentaro, who's
the guy who made "Black Cat",
he has this thing in all of his manga.
So he also illustrated
"To Love Ru" as well.
- One of Joey's favorites.
- And I mean, it is fucking good.
But he has this like
kind of Easter egg thing
in all of his manga where in
every chapter of his manga,
he puts this like little white
cat in at least one panel
of every chapter of his manga,
just as like a little hidden Easter egg.
And it's that cat face
that I use as my mask.
So like originally like
fucking back way back when,
on like New Grounds and shit like that,
that was just my logo.
And then I, and then it
adopted into my current avatar,
but like, I don't know, "Black
Cat" was like, it's weird.
It's definitely heavy nostalgia factor.
But I think this was the first
time I ever read a manga.
And I was like,
"Wow, like manga artists
are fucking talented."
(Garnt laughs)
- It was the first time
where I was actually
wowed by a piece of art.
- Do you want to explain
what happens in it.
I can try and explain,
but I honestly can't remember anything.
- It's been a while.
- Yeah, it's been a while
for me as well so like,
do you want to try explaining it?
- He's not a black cat.
- [Joey] No.
- But that's like his code name?
- Yeah.
- He's an assassin right?
- He's an assassin.
He's number 13.
- That's it.
- His name is Train.
- He has two guns.
- Train Hearnet, I believe his name was.
- Two guns?
- Oh is that it?
- Yeah.
- Train Heartnet.
- Is it two guns?
- Yeah, He has two guns.
- Two pistols.
- Yeah.
- And he shoots people.
- Then there's Sven and Eve,
I believe were the names.
- Sven and Eve, okay.
- I remember that this was the first
because I just got into anime.
It's the only thing I remember about it.
This was the first show that I was like,
"Yeah, you know what?
Not every anime is above a seven.
Fuck."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- This is the first show that I was like,
" I'm going to teach you a lesson
as an example to the other
anime, you're a five."
You know what I mean?
Like I gave it a lower
score than I would have
just to be like, "Yeah, you know what?
I'm fair."
- Just to prove a point.
- I give out fair scores.
So okay I give it a five.
- I think I remember
watching like a few episodes
of "Black Cat" years ago.
And it was just me...
It was just that phase where
you'd watch everything.
And then I was like,
"Cool, guy in a black coat.
He looks kind of cool.
I'll watch a few episodes."
And it was just like, "Wow, I am-"
- So what happens in it?
- Extremely whelmed.
- So "Black Cat" is like, he kind of,
so Train, obviously he starts
off as this like assassin,
but then he escapes from the
organization that he's part of.
And he basically the entire manga,
he gets chased by the organization members
to come back to the organization.
'Cause he has like all
the secrets or whatever.
And like there's a dude
in the organization
or I think who also left the organization,
who is like,
he's basically like the
quintessential male Yandere.
Like it's really, like, I
remember the main bad guy is like,
I dunno, I've never really heard
of like a male Yandere
antagonist before in a manga.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Especially in a Shonen manga.
- I just realized, out of
context, you kind of sound like
you're describing John Wick or something.
- (Joey laughs) A little.
- It's like "And he left the organization
and he is an ex assassin."
- Who uses gold coins.
They killed his dog.
They killed his black cat.
(everyone laughs)
- How dare they.
How dare they.
- He's on a mission to
tear down the organization.
- But yeah, basically, and
then like Sven is the guy
who like, has like a, he's
like an explosives expert.
And then Eve is this he's like this
she's like this test
tube, like experimental.
- This is when every single manga
had to have like a ragtag band of people
who could do special things.
And have comedy.
- Okay so, why is this
in your three-by-three?
I'm so curious.
- It's in my three-by-three
because it was one of the first mangas...
Okay, so when I was
growing up reading manga,
I obviously started off
reading things like "Doraemon"
and like, you know,
"KoroKoro" comic magazine,
which is more aimed towards kids
under the age of 10 years old.
- [Connor] Right.
- And then when I got to
around 10, 11 years old,
I was like, "Oh, you know what?
'Doraemon', 'KoroKoro' stuff,
it's a bit too young for me?"
- I've got a big pee pee now.
- I'm a big boy now.
I'm about to enter middle school, right.
I want to read some of this middle school-
- "Gantz."
So I was like, you know, I want to read
this like Shonen Jump thing
that I keep hearing all my
Japanese friends talk about.
- Yeah.
- So at the time
I borrowed one of my friends
Shonen Jump magazines.
And I think that particular magazine
"Black Cat" was on the cover of it.
- Oh, okay.
- Because "Black Cat" had like,
because like every month,
every week on Shonen Jump,
they have like-
- Change the cover.
- Yeah they changed the cover.
You some chapters have like,
you know, colored pages
and some of them are like
have like center covers
and stuff like that.
And I think "Black Cat"
had a front color chapter.
And again, like, you know,
you go from the "Doraemon" to this, right.
Like clearly this is going to make you go,
"Whoa, what the fuck is that?"
And so, yeah.
And I think like, honestly
I really enjoyed it.
I mean, Yabuki Kentaro I think
still makes some fucking
godly character designs.
I mean, you know, the
reason why "To Lover Ru"
was so fucking infamous
is because like the character
designs fucking cute,
like he knows how to draw
really just aesthetic looking
characters and like, you know,
"Black Cat" I feel was definitely when
he was still kind of in
his like younger times.
Where like he hadn't quite refined
his art, but near the end of "Black Cat"
his art just got better and
better and better and better.
- Okay.
- And like, I don't know.
It's just like
it's nothing like deep or anything
or like profounding in any way.
It's just a really solid Shonen manga
with like really just intricate, nice art.
- Would it hold up today?
- You know what?
I haven't read it in quite a while.
I did-
- Would you recommend it
to someone to read now?
- It's hard.
It's really hard because like, I dunno,
'cause I'm obviously looking at the show,
because this shows very closely to me.
- It's nostalgical.
- It's very nostalgical,
obviously looking at this
with like rose tinted gloss.
So like, I don't know.
Maybe if you're a fan of
like "Yabuki Kintaro" stuff.
If you liked what you saw on "To Love Ru."
- [Connor] Okay.
- And want like that, with action.
- Does it, is the story
just kind of wrap up?
Does have a good conclusion.
- Yeah, it does.
Actually, it has a really nice conclusion.
And like the final fight
with like the male Yandere antagonist,
who's a really fucking
interesting character.
And the powers and everything
they're like super cool.
- Yeah.
- I dunno.
It's again, it's just like a really solid
Shonen Jump manga that's like
very inoffensive, I feel.
- I think this was the start
of the the time where I started realize
that anime sometimes
just don't have endings.
(Joey laughs)
And I was like-
- What do you mean?
- Well because I started off
with "Death Note", "Code
Geass", "Fullmetal Alchemist."
I'm like, "Sick, these are great."
- You spoiled yourself.
You literally spoiled all
of anime for yourself.
- Yeah.
- No I did not.
I had a great time.
And then I started getting into shows-
- Because what I mean,
is that no other anime,
that just is a normal anime,
is just going to live
up to those standards.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, so then I started
watching shows and I'm like,
"Wait, why didn't this end?"
(Joey laughs)
Where's the ending?
And this is when, this is how, you know,
everyone else had the
same desperation as me.
'Cause whenever you type in the show,
the first auto-fillers,
"When is season three
coming out of this show?"
"There are no plans for
season three of this show."
- Literally when you click like,
when you type in "No Game No Life",
you know what I mean?
- Or like "Spice and Wolf."
- Because everyone's like,
"Wait, why would there
not be a season two?
This was a popular show, right?
There's season 2 coming right?
Right?
Right!"
- Never happened.
- And then this is when
I started to realize...
I'm like, "Oh, they're just
not going to finish shows.
They're just going to like release shows?"
- They just going to be
like, "We released it.
We're not going to finish it.
Fuck you, go read the manga."
- This is where sometimes I wish anime
was produced by Americans
because you know that
it would fucking end.
They might not be good, but
you know it's coming out.
- And that's why I feel like manga
takes more of the same form
as like American TV shows.
Because some manga just
go on for fucking ever.
And like, you're just like,
"You know, I don't, I'm not...
I don't know if I'm even invested
to see this end anymore."
Right?
- Then anime will make
like a billion dollars
and they're like, no, I don't
think we need another...
No there's no more seasons.
- Because like sometimes,
sometimes an anime makes
like a billion dollars,
but then it's like 100th
of the entire story.
And you're just like, how are they going?
Like, how are they ever going
to adapt the entire story?
It's going to take like
fucking 10 decades to do this.
And so, you know,
there are some stories
where I'm just like, I just,
I know I'm never going to
see the end of the anime.
And even like manga form,
like I'm still waiting.
Like fucking "Ipo."
Like, oh how long is
"Ipo" going to go on for?
- True.
- Right? Like Jesus.
- Or "Baki."
- Or "Baki" right?
- "Baki" should go on forever.
- Yeah "Baki" should go on forever.
- Speaking of "Baki", obviously Baki's...
The fucking Itgaki sends
his daughter "Beastars",
fucking amazing manga.
- That's like the newest
one that's on there right?
- That's probably the newest one.
Like after I finished reading
"Beastars" I was like,
"Oh, that is so close to
a modern masterpiece."
- [Connor] How come-
- In terms of manga.
- How come "Baki" isn't on here?
- "Baki", I don't know.
Like for me, "Baki" is one of those shows
where it's like, it's good,
don't get me wrong.
It's fucking amazing.
And it's so unique, but
I feel that it's like,
there are some parts where it's just like,
it's just a blur when you
read it, you know what I mean?
Or it's like,
it's so long and there's so
much shit that happens in it
that it's just so insane and ridiculous
that you think of one fight scene
and it blends in with about
10 other fight scenes.
- Actually yeah that's true.
- That's true.
- Fair enough.
- Like part two for example, right,
With the whole Tournament arc.
I'm just like,
I can only remember maybe
like one or two fights.
I re-read it the other day-
- The fights were kinda underwhelming.
- There's like 20 fights in the manga.
- Yeah, and in the anime
they only showed like four.
- Yeah, right.
- But that's pretty good
because most of them
are kind of underwhelming.
- Yeah, true, true.
- A lot of the fights, even in the anime,
they only showed like six and I was like,
"Eh, 3 of these are boring."
- Like with "Baki", you
remember the most like notable,
like meme worthy ridiculous
type of scenes, right.
Whereas with "Beastars", for example,
it was like just as
like one cohesive story,
it was just:
A, really fucking
unique, really done well.
And it's just, yeah.
- Has it concluded?
- Yep, it ended.
- When did it finish?
It couldn't have been too long ago?
- About a year ago.
- So how many seasons of the anime
do you think there should be
if we were to adapt everything?
- To adapt everything?
- Yeah.
- So we're at season two right now,
which is, oh, I probably shouldn't say.
- [Connor] Oh.
- Where we're up to in season two. But-
- I haven't watched it yet.
That's probably about
volume seven or eight.
- And how many volumes are there?
- Over 20.
(Garnt winces)
- Well to be fair wasn't
season three announced already?
- I think so.
- Yeah.
- I'm sure Netflix wants
to keep that coming.
And I am very happy with that.
Please do.
- [Joey] And it gets more and
more interesting after that.
- I'm hoping we finally
get a fucking anime
that finishes in anime form.
We never fucking get it
anymore, it's bullshit.
- I mean we're getting it like the...
The latest one I can think
of that we're getting
is "Attack on Titan" and that's only like
one of the most successful
anime of all time.
- So it takes the whole
fucking world watching it
for them to be like, "Maybe we
could just finish this one."
It's like if the streamers
are like start new anime,
finish old one.
And then like, "I like though..."
No!
Stop!
Finish this one.
Finish this!
- It's just like, if an anime
gets over three seasons,
like, because even if, even
if we get a season two,
that's just like getting
the table scraps, right.
You're like, "Oh my God.
I can't believe I've got a season two."
(Connor panting)
- Is this an OVA?
- May I have some more?
- May I have some more.
And then for some reason there's
like fucking four seasons
of "Mahouka" or something.
I'd like, "Well, what's going on?"
- There's be like 10 seasons of-
- There's a fucking spin off of Mahouka.
- I'm like nobody asked for this.
- There'll be like fucking
10 seasons of "Saki",
like playing mash off.
And I'm like, "Oh, fuck off."
Fuck off, is this doing well?
You cannot tell me this
deserves a second season
and "No Game No Life" doesn't?
- [Joey] Yeah.
Exactly.
- Fuck right off.
- But yeah so "Beastars"...
So you think it's like up there
as the modern classic now?
'Cause I-
- I think so.
The ending wasn't exactly
like amazing, amazing.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It was just a solid ending.
- If we get the full anime
adaptation of the manga
in the way that it's
going right now, right.
Would it would be
considered a masterpiece?
(Joey sighs)
- Man, I personally would see it
as like easy nine out of 10, at least.
- I mean I can see that.
If the anime keeps up
the quality of a story.
Because I love season one,
but it felt like season one
just felt like a kind of a setup season.
- It's like the ending of
"Beastars" is very much like,
the ending of part six.
Where it's like the people
who love it, love it.
But the people who didn't
like it were like, "Eh."
You know?
- Yeah. I mean-
- It's like a lot of people say
that it's like kind of
an anticlimactic ending
but I thought it was kind of fitting
to how the entire story went.
Because like the final part of "Beastars"
there's like this big fight that happens.
- [Connor] Obviously.
- Yeah, of course, right.
- And then from that big fight,
it kind of suddenly winds down
into just like regular stuff.
- [Connor] Okay.
- And like to a lot of people
that was seen as "anticlimactic."
- Sometimes I like that though.
I like a little breathing
time to say goodbye.
- [Joey] Yeah right.
- You know what I mean?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I like to, "All right guys,
just going of read a few more chapters
with you guys before you
guys fuck off forever."
(Connor fake cries)
- 'Cause like what gets me
sometimes is I know like
there's always the hype around
the last chapter, right?
Because the last chapter you're
saying goodbye to everything
and you know, this is,
this is where this is...
And people like try to put a
conclusion in the last chapter.
Whereas some of like my favorite manga
is when that last chapter is just,
the climax is over.
It's done.
It's purely just an epilogue.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like epilogues
are so fucking underrated.
- Yeah.
- In so many anime and manga,
because most of the time,
it's just like you get to
the final episode, right?
And half of this episode is the climax.
So you've got like 10
minutes to say goodbye
to all these characters.
You've grown-
- [Connor] Give me a full episode.
Give me a full episode.
- Yeah, give me a full episode.
- I hate the epilogues that are like,
there's like seven minutes
left of the episode.
It's like, "Are they going
to stick the landing?"
And then you know that
it's a rushed epilogue
when they start talking
and the ending song plays.
- Yeah, no no no.
And it's not even,
it's not even an epilogue.
It's just like a slide show.
(Joey laughs)
- Of just like here
are the characters now.
- Oh, here they go.
- They're going away.
- There they go.
- And then we have "Ichigo
100%", which again,
for me is like another, I
wouldn't even, it's weird.
- What's this about? I've heard-
- Please explain this.
- Okay, so is "Ichigo
100%" is just this really
just super simple romcom, essentially.
Like, you know how Shonen
Jump, every time, right,
they replace harem romcoms right?
Like once one harem romcom ends,
another one takes its place kind of thing.
- [Connor] True yeah.
- Okay.
- "Ichigo 100%" was probably-
- It's like the "Terminator."
- Yeah, pretty much.
- "Ichigo 100%" was the one
that, well, first of all,
like it was like right at its prime
when I started reading Shonen Jump.
So again, big nostalgia factor,
I'm going to completely admit that.
But second of all, to me,
it is like the one manga series
where there was no one clear winner.
Like right up until the end.
It was like all the girls are
so liked through and through.
Like people think
"Quintessential Quintuplets"
is like the ultimate,
like "any one of these girls
could win" type of thing.
It's like-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- No, no, it's not.
"Ichigo 100%" is.
Because you start off with liking one girl
as you do with any harem romcom right.
- [Connor] Of course.
- Of course.
- But "Ichigo 100%",
I don't know how the fuck
Kawashita Mizuki did it,
but she did it in a way
where by the end of it,
any one of them could win.
But you don't know who.
Like right up until the end.
And it's just so simple, but so well done.
And again, I really like
Kawashita Mizuki art style
because again, very different.
It almost doesn't even look-
- It looks super 90's.
- [Joey] Yeah, oh yeah.
I mean because it is very nineties.
- [Connor] They all look
like the Chobits robots.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah they do!
- [Joey] A little bit yeah.
I mean it's around the same era.
- It looks like the exact same
characters design as well.
- Yeah they look like
they're like all robots.
- And it's weird right because-
- We are programmed to
fall in love with you.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep.
- And it's weird, right?
Because it's like, to me,
it's not even the best
romcom manga, in my opinion.
- [Connor] Oh okay.
- Okay.
- I think-
- So is this a harem romcom?
- Harem romcom.
- Which we all know
that Joey loves a good-
- I like a good harem romcom.
- Joey loves a good-
- I love a good harem romcom.
Don't get me wrong.
In my opinion, the best romcom
manga ever written is "Eyes"
which is also from Shonen Jump.
Which came before this one.
So like this one
basically replaced "Eyes."
- I've heard of "Eyes."
That got an anime
adaptation didn't that in?
- In like early 2000's I think.
- Yeah it was like a very shit adaptation.
I think.
- It wasn't a very good adaptation.
- It was forgettable.
That's all I know.
- But yeah, it's done by the
same guy who made "Zetman."
- Oh, okay okay.
- And like all of those.
He's done a lot of manga.
But yeah, I dunno.
Again, this was one of those
shows that I think this show
is the reason why I love harem romcoms.
- Okay, so do you read the...
Did you watch the anime
adaptation of this at all?
- Was it anime?
- Yeah there is anime.
- Yeah there is, there
is an anime adaptation.
It's not good.
- Oh.
- Basically every, like-
- Joey's like, "There is an anime.
Just don't read it.
Just watch the shows."
- Like basically most of the shows on here
have like very mediocre anime adaptations.
Aside from like-
- The only, except for "Beastars"-
- Aside from "Beastars"
I'd argue "Yu Yu Hakusho"
but that's just me.
- "Beastars" and...
Yeah probably "Yu Yu Hakusho" and "JoJo."
- Okay, "JoJo."
Well Part 6 hasn't got a dub yet.
- Well Part 6 yeah.
- It's coming.
- Hopefully it's good.
- It's coming, oh it's going to-
- It's coming.
- Oh it's going to-
- Oh Lord she coming.
- Oh Lord he coming.
- Oh you know it's going to be good.
- But yeah, and then we have, Uzimaki-
- Of course, of course.
- Junji Ito.
- Honestly anything from Junji
Ito could have been in here.
Again, he's probably the
reason why I love horror manga.
- I mean, I do think "Uzimaki" is like,
kind of like in terms of like a long form,
I think it is his magnum opus.
- I think so.
- Some of my favorite works
of Jinji Yuto isn't "Uzimaki."
But just his one shots actually.
- Yeah.
- I feel like "Uzimaki" is
his like only long form work
that I think is like the best.
- Yeah, and again, like
that's why I feel like I could
have put anything in there.
Like I also fucking love "Tomie"
which was his first one that he made.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is also brilliantly horrifying.
Like if you love like your
kind of body dysmorphia,
McCobb horror type of thing.
- I do really want to read
Junji Ito at some point.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's part of the-
- It's a trip.
- It's on the infinite list of,
"I need to get right into that."
- Well it's just like with Jinji Ito,
you don't even need to
like be that invested in it
because I, like,
I think the best entry point for Jinji Ito
is just to read some of his one shots.
- Yeah.
Because like, I feel like,
one there's only like a few genres
that really worked well with one shots
and horror is some of them.
Because all he has to do is like,
he hits you with this like
really weird fucking idea.
And then it just ends.
- It's, yeah.
It's like he definitely
like has taken a lot
of inspiration from like
classic Asian horror
in the sense that the stories
don't necessarily make sense.
But at the end of it,
you're somehow still
invested and still terrified.
- Yeah.
- It's purely that he
purely just assaults you-
- Yeah.
- With all of these senses of
just super disturbing shit.
And then kind of just
like, that's the end.
How do you feel?
- How do you feel?
Take a seat.
- Why you here?
(guys laughing)
- I'm sold.
- Yeah, so obviously
I think it's no secret
that I love-
- Jinji Ito , yeah.
- Stuff.
- And then I guess we just
talk about the center one.
- Yeah.
- There's a reason why
I put it in the center
'cause I still think to this day
it's one of the greatest
manga series ever made.
- It's the one manga series that I know.
Like I'm building myself
up to be ready for.
- [Connor] Yeah, it's like
I haven't watched the last
season of "BoJack Horseman."
It's not because I don't want to.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm just kind of not in the mindset
where I want to be depressed.
- I mean you know, with
your three-by-three, right.
You were talking about like
the one that you enjoyed the most
and the one you think is
the best is different.
- Yeah.
- This is definitely that.
- The one that you think is the best?
- I did not enjoy reading
"Oyasumi Punpun" at all.
- Yeah like you don't enjoy it.
But you just can't stop.
- Yeah.
- But it's one of those...
I know this, even though
I've never read it,
it's one of those series or stories,
from what I understand
that it's just it hits you.
- Yeah.
- And it sticks with you and it's like,
you read it once and
it's just a part of you.
- I've just got like shit to do you know.
Like I'm going to be sad for like a while.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I got to deal with that.
- I remember I binged this
manga for the first time
and I finished reading it at like 4:00 AM.
- Yeah.
- And I just kind of,
the moment I finished it,
I just kind of closed it
and just sat on my couch.
- I know exactly...
Because that's like me after
every "BoJack" episode.
And then they're like
automatically playing the next one.
Like, "No, no, no.
Give me a second."
- Give me some time to recover.
- Give me a minute man.
Just give me a minute.
That was so depressing.
- But I think the one
thing that I really like
about "Oyasumi Punpun" is the fact
that it almost goes beyond manga.
Like what Ino Asano
did to "Oyasumi Punpun"
is so like...
We were talking about
metaphors before, right,
with, you know, "EyeShield
21" stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- The metaphors in "Oyasumi
Punpun" are insane.
- Right.
Because literally like
what kind of mangaka
has the balls to turn their
main character into a metaphor?
- I think it's genius.
- I think it's absolutely genius.
So to explain "Oyasumi
Punpun" for those of you
that don't know.
This is the main character.
His name is Punpun.
He's a bird character
and every other character
in the manga is a human.
- Yeah.
- But all the human characters
see Punpun as a human.
- It's...
Okay, so it's like how he sees himself
is different from everyone else.
- Yes.
It's how he sees himself.
But it's also how you, as
the reader, see him as well.
So like throughout the
manga as he's gone...
So basically it's this manga
where it follows the life
of Punpun growing up.
So he starts off as a kid
and he turns into a teenager
and then turns into an adult.
- Oh I already don't
like the sound of this.
I don't like shows that
follow them growing up.
I know its going to be fucked.
- At it kind very slowly, yet steadily,
it goes through every inch of his life.
- Oh I don't like those.
- There's a lot of
things that happen to him
and around him that are very fucked.
- Yeah that's how-
- Yeah so like it starts
off with him as a kid.
He meets this girl, you know,
learns what falling in love is.
Learns the the joys and
the heartbreak of puberty.
And then-
- I feel you man.
- And then that drags on with him.
And then he has family problems.
He has problems with his friends.
He has problems with who he is-
- Basically just a broken life, you know.
- It's a broken life. And-
- No!
- And what's so brilliant
about "Oyasumi Punpun"
is that as, obviously, you know,
like when he like gets
older, he gets bigger,
taller, but still the bird.
But then there are certain
points in the manga
where his look completely changes.
So there's one part in the manga
where he just turns
into a floating pyramid
for about two chapters.
- Oh.
- Okay.
- And it's not really
explained why it happens.
- But as you're reading it in context,
it represents something in him.
- [Connor] Okay
- Okay.
- And it's very, literal in that sense.
- I'll read it.
How long is it, how many chapters?
- Seven volumes.
- Oh.
- I own all of them.
I've owned all of them for years.
It's been sitting-
- It's 12 volumes, I think.
- Okay, well-
- It's 120 something chapters
- Garnt's like, "Shit
okay, so I own 7 of them."
- Well no.
I believe, at least
the translated volumes.
- Yeah the Western
volumes are a lot thicker
- They're a lot thicker.
So I have, I own the-
- There's 13 volumes in Japan.
But it's like 120 something chapters.
- So you could probably
read it in one day.
- You could easily read it in one day.
I mean I read it in one day.
- Like, it's been sitting on
my shelf, I think for years.
It's just been staring at me.
And I'm like, I stare at it.
And I'm just like, "Is today
the day today I read it."
- Just the thought about it-
- Nope I'm happy today.
- Just the thought about reading it,
I hear like "Guts" theme in my head.
- Yeah, basically.
- My very first experience
with hearing about "Oyasumi Punpun"
was when I actually started dating Sydney.
And, so...
This was back when I didn't
know Sydney too well.
And she gets really,
really invested in stories
end of stories.
And she's one of those
people that, you know,
that gets truly gets invested
and involved into a piece of fiction.
So I'm just here sitting in my room,
sitting in my office doing like
YouTube videos or whatever.
And then I hear Sydney just like balling.
I mean, this is like,
I'd never seen her cry harder than this.
- Yeah.
- Like, she was like,
like beyond ugly crying.
- Yeah.
- You know, it was like,
I came in and like my-
- Honey what's wrong?
- My gut just sank because
like, I've only like,
this is the kind of reaction you see
when someone's family
member just died, you know?
(Joey laughs)
And I'm just like, I
take a few deep breaths.
I'm like, "Okay, I know,
I know we're going to have to
deal with something serious."
- Yeah
- Something really fucked
up And I'm just like,
"Honey, are you okay?
What happened?"
And she just went,
"I just finished a manga."
(Joey laughs)
- And I dead ass just went, "What, what?"
And she's like, "It's
called 'Oyasumi Punpun'."
I'm just like, "I am going
back in my office now."
- Here's some Kleenex.
Clean yourself up.
(Garnt laughs)
- But yeah like I-
- I mean like I didn't like
ugly sob at the end of "Punpun"-
- Yeah.
- But there were definitely
moments throughout "Punpun"
that I kind of just opened my eyes wide
and I was like, "Holy shit."
Like, there are many times
where I actually said to myself out loud,
I was like, "No, no."
- Not this like.
- [Joey] Yeah not like this.
And it's like, and again, it's like,
it's the way that he can somehow fit
this fucking bird character
into a super realistic context
of like very realistic setting
with very realistic characters.
And give this bird
the most human life
possible is so insane to me.
And the fact that he can
just do it seamlessly.
Like, you know, obviously at first,
if you're going into this blind.
- Yeah.
- First couple of pages, you're like,
"What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this bird?"
- Yeah true.
- But you kind of like
learn to grow with it.
And again, like, you know, it's,
it's one of those things
where like a lot of people say
like, "Oh, he turned it into a bird
so that you yourself
can put yourself into
Punpun's situations."
- Yeah yeah.
- [Connor] Sounds like it.
- So that you're not fixated
on one particular type
of person, you know,
when concerning looks and stuff like that.
Like you can just imagine
this as any human.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- And it's just, yeah.
And again, it's like Inio
Asano literally just took
all these like rudimentary
concepts about manga
and just went throw out
the window and just went...
I just going to draw what I think is cool
And it's like, there's lots
of like weird shit in it
as well.
But like, I mean, I've been
trying to write a video
about his manga for so long.
But literally every time
I reread it, first of all,
I get destroyed for about a week.
So I try not to do it.
But second of all,
there was just so many subtle things in it
that I keep picking up
on that I didn't before.
That just completely
makes me change the way
I view this manga.
And it's just, yeah, it's insane.
So I like, again, probably the
manga, I enjoyed the least.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- But definitely one of the best.
I thought that's what I
assumed it was going to be.
- Yeah.
- Which is just like,
I'm not reading this manga to enjoy it.
I'm reading this manga because I know
it's probably going to be
one of the most like
powerful pieces of media
I've ever consumed.
- Yeah.
- And that's like my
assumption going into it.
- And the final chapter made
me cry, like fucking crazy.
I was like, "Fuck man."
It was brutal.
But yeah, I don't know
what else I can talk about.
Yeah, I realized that, you know,
even though I've read a lot
of manga, you know what,
at the end of the day,
Shonen Jumps just kind
of the king to be honest.
- I mean it's kind of the king for, it's-
- That's how it's always been.
- You can't hate it.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean Shonen Jump just has a formula.
And I don't know what that
formula is, but they just keep-
- It works.
- They just keep pumping out
bangers, not just bangers,
like everything they
pump out just seems to be
like a global sensation.
- Yeah.
- And even if it's not,
it's going to have some kind
of cult following behind it.
- It's just kind of the ones
that I remember the most for some reason.
- Like, like fucking now,
I remember when the Big Three
ended or like, you know,
"Naruto", not the big three,
but the era of the Big Three
were "Naruto", "Bleach" and "One Piece".
"One Piece" is obviously still going on,
but everyone was just like,
"What's going to replace it?
How can anything replace
'Naruto' and 'Bleach'?"
Those were like global sensations.
Then "My Hero" came out and was just like,
"Hold my my beer."
And then "Demon Slayer" came out
and it was just like, "Hold my sword."
And then like fucking
now, "Jujitsu Kaisan"
and now like "Chain Saw Man"'s coming out.
- Yeah.
- Which is going to be
a massive fucking hit.
- Yeah.
- Like where did they miss?
When did I like-
- They don't.
- Are they fucking aim boxing?
Like, what's their secret?
(Joey laughs)
- Like what the fuck is going on?
- We don't miss!
No legit.
And it's like, you know, again, it's like,
you know, you kind of get in that period
of your manga reading life
where you're just like,
"You know what, maybe,
maybe it's time to
graduate from the Shonens."
- Yeah.
- You know, it's, it's like,
it's kind of formulaic.
I want to try something new.
So you go out,
read some of the more obscure Sanin manga
or the Shojo or the
Jose manga or, you know,
some like weird gore or edgy type of shit.
And it's like, there's lots of good ones.
Don't get me wrong.
But at the end of the day,
you're always going to
go back to Shonen Jump.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what it is.
I remember I said that opinion on Twitter
and I got a lot of shit for it.
And I'm like look-
- I agree.
- I'm just spitting the facts, man.
There's a reason why it's
still the greatest selling-
- They hated him because
he told the truth.
- Exactly.
So, yeah, I don't know.
Is it normy?
- I don't know, is "Berserk" normy?
- I don't know.
- I feel like "Berserk" is legendary.
- I just, seeing the fact
that more than half of
these are Shonen Jump.
- I will say this now, I've got "Berserk"
on my three-by-three as well.
And I was just like, "Can
I justify not putting
"Berserk" on my three-by-three?"
I just went through these,
like this mental gymnastic of just like,
"Is there any manga
that I could like
feasibly put over Berserk?
No."
- No.
- Like, it's the GOAT for a reason.
- It's one of a kind.
- Guess we could talk
about it at the end maybe.
- Yeah, we can definitely talk about it.
- But honestly like-
- Good three-by-three.
- No, no trash taste here.
You have a very solid list.
- Thank you.
- Obviously there are
some that I haven't seen.
- Seems well-rounded though.
- Again I had to recommend to anyone,
who's never read any of these.
Obviously "Berserk", please go read that.
"Beastars", fucking fantastic.
And if you can handle it,
please read "Oyasumi Punpun."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Right.
- [Joey] It will change your life.
- I do want to read most of these.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean "Slam Dunk" as
well is one of the greatest-
- Yeah I want to read "Slam Dunk" too.
- It's fucking amazing.
- How many chap-
because like fuck dude.
"EyeShield 21" took me a long time.
It's got a lot of chapters.
- "Slam Dunk"'s got 30 volumes.
- Oh shit.
- It's long.
- It's going to take you some time.
- Fuck.
- I mean, I'd say there's
a lot of these that-
- But the payoff is insane.
- All right, all right,
all right, all right.
- If you like your sports manga,
you kind of need to read "Slam Dunk."
- I do, I do.
- If you like sports manga you'll like it.
- This is the quintessential sports manga.
- And that is Joey's taste.
You can judge.
I mean, we've had two very
solid three-by-threes now.
- Let's see if we can
keep up that momentum.
- I'm kind of worried about mine now.
I'm like, "Oh shit."
- Ashley put up Garnt's three-by-three.
- All right, let's take a break.
- Okay, yeah.
- Garnt's like "Quick manga version."
- This episode is sponsored by Manscaped.
- Do you have a problem
maintaining your bush.
If so, Manscaped is here to help you.
- Thank God for Manscape
because I sure do have
a problem with my bush.
- Luckily, or unfortunately,
Joey's bush is doing better
than Australia right now.
And thus, he needs the Lawn Mower 4.0,
which is Manscaped's some
brand new Lawn Mower.
- Join the two million men worldwide
who trust Manscaped TM
by going to manscape.com/trashtaste
for 20% off and free shipping.
- It's hot as hell right now.
And you know what
doesn't need to be moist?
Your pubes.
- These nuts.
- And thanks to Manscaped,
I don't have to worry about these nuts.
Ready for an out of
world experience fellas.
Well look, no further than
the Performance Package 4.0.
(Joey gasps)
- Damn.
That's a lot of performance in a package.
- [Joey] Well inside this package
you'll find their Lawn Mower 4.0 trimmer,
Weed Whacker ear and nose hair trimmer,
Crop Preserver, ball deodorant,
Crop Reviver toner,
performance boxer briefs,
and a travel bag to hold
all of your stuff in.
- God damn.
And you can get this in the
U.S. and Canada and the UK
and across Europe, Australia,
South Africa, and Singapore.
- Anywhere in the world you
need your balls trimmed,
Manscaped's got you.
- [Connor] The Weed
Whackers is also waterproof
and uses a 9,000 RPM motor powered
by a 360 degree rotary Juul blade system.
- So if you want to protect these nuts,
then go to manscape.com/trashtaste
for 20% off your order and free shipping.
- That's 20% off plus
free shipping by going to
manscape.com/trashtaste.
If you also want to become
a Sigma male use Manscaped.
- These nuts back to the episode.
- If you guys read "Punpun"
I'll read "Hunter x Hunter".
- All right.
Go on, pull up my three-by-three.
- Pull up the three-by-three.
Let's see.
- Some of these that
shouldn't be surprises at all.
(Joey laughs)
- [Joey] Okay okay.
Okay well let's got through the order.
- It's a mix.
- Wow.
- So before we get into it,
there are some that I feel
like I would put in there
if there wasn't already like
an amazing anime adaptation
of it.
- Right.
- I really wanted to put
"Vinland Saga" on there
for example, but I'm just like, well,
I also really, really
enjoyed the anime, so-
- Do you want to go through them?
- Okay.
So from going down from a
"Great Teacher Onizuka",
"Kingdom", "The Breaker",
"20th Century Boys",
"Domestic Girlfriend",
"Love Hina", "Berserk",
"Beck", and "Psyren."
- [Joey] "Psyren", really?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] I was not expecting "Psyren."
- What is...
Is "Breaker" the Korean one?
- That's amanhwa.
- Yeah, yeah.
To me like Breaker.
I'll start off on "Breaker"
because that's the only one
on there that is actually
not actually a manga, but amanhwa.
I feel like "Breaker"
is that one, it takes,
it's basically everything I
wanted from a Shonen anime
that you could not get
for then Shonen Jump.
Because it takes the kind
of the Shonen Jump-like
battle manga formula, and
adds martial arts to it.
And it's so rare to see something,
to see a manga that just
does martial arts well.
And I've kind of realized
if I'm looking for martial
arts, because you know,
if you watch the film three-by-threes
you'd know that I'm a huge
fucking fan of Kung Fu movies
and stuff like that.
And it's just so hard to
find that same vibe in manga.
- But amanhwa does martial arts,
I mean, you know, "God of
High School" as well, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
So you got like "God of High School."
- They don't really care
about kung-fu in Japan.
- Yeah, exactly.
- In a sense almost, yeah.
- Yeah almost.
But like Veratuas is
like the perfect balance
between martial arts and superpowers
because people are like
still very human in there
and you know, you can still
take someone out with a gun,
but they have enough power
that they're kind of also
superhuman as well, right.
So it's kind of balanced in that way.
And it's like, it's got
like a very, you know,
it's got a very standard story.
It's about this guy who has
zero martial arts powers
and zero ki, as you know, which
is the power system there.
And he just meets this
guy who was, you know,
he's beating up some street thugs
and turns out he's just
like a fucking, you know,
martial arts master or whatever.
- Right right.
- And so to help teach this
guy or to help this guy
basically like protect himself
and not be bullied and all that,
he gives him like this
medicine, which you know,
is technically he gave it to
him by accident and ends up
this guy is just like,
obviously a secret genius in martial arts
and kind of like takes on the
entire martial arts world.
- Performance enhancing drugs.
- [Garnt] Of course.
- Always say yes.
- Of course.
- We figured use a hundred
percent of your brain.
- But like, it's, it's like-
- It sounds cool though.
- But like in terms of like formula, yeah.
It's a very, very standard
formula, but one, okay,
like the art is fucking fantastic.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I mean the cover looks amazing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
It's so it's like so much more detailed
than you see in a lot
of just standard Shonen Jump manga, right.
And what blows my mind
is that this was like a weekly release,
but the art quality is that of
like a monthly release manga.
- Right.
- You know what I mean?
Like "One Punch Man" for example,
is a monthly release, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So you can see why, you
know, it took the time to be,
to make it a monthly manga.
This was released weekly
and it's not as good as "One Punch Man"
in terms of art quality.
But it's like way better
than pretty much most standard
Shonen Jump weekly manga.
- Damn.
- And it's like the action choreography
and the action art is fucking insane.
And it's just like pure fun.
It's just pure...
You know what you're getting,
this guy is like a weakling, okay.
But the amount of times
that he fucking does
something badass unexpectedly
is just like, it's just insane.
And he keeps like the stakes
keep rising and rising.
And what I love as well is
they've really built up,
I really loved the world building
of just like the secret organization
that's of like martial artists.
- [Connor] Of course.
- Who like kind of rule the
world, you know, it's like-
- Like in real life.
- Yeah, yeah.
Kinda like in real life kind of thing.
It's got like the same
kind of like vibe as John,
the "John Wick" world,
if you know what I mean,
- I'm down for that.
I love John Wick.
- Obviously the main
protagonist isn't John Wick.
It's someone who grows into someone
who's going to be that
skilled in that world.
- Right, right.
- But it's kind of got that same vibe
in world building and it's just,
I fucking love it.
And not enough people
talk about "The Breaker."
- I've definitely heard of the title
because it's just one
of those shows you hear
when someone says, "Oh, you know,
I know a fucking amazing manhwa."
Or like...
What was the other one?
"Solo Leveling"?
- "Solo Leveling" yeah.
- That like I hear a lot of
and that I really need to read.
- [Connor] Oh I hear that too.
- I mean "Solo Leveling"
I feel is it's good,
but it's, I dunno why "Solo
Leveling" works so well.
It's basically just an Isaki in disguise,
but for some reason, it feels,
I think it's mostly carried by the arts.
- Right right.
- The arts just amazing.
- Dude, manhwa art is like next level.
- I don't know how they
do it so consistently.
- Literally every manhwa I've read
has just been like, "Oh my God."
- I really don't know
how they do it so fucking consistently.
- Yeah, it's insane.
- And then-
- Yeah.
What else did we want to talk about?
- "Kingdom"?
I haven't read "Kingdom."
I've been considering it.
- I've read the first
five volumes of "Kingdom"
because I read it-
- It's long right?
- Yeah, it's 60 volumes.
- It's it's like...
Okay, okay.
- [Joey] It's still going.
- 60?!
- It's still going too.
- Okay, okay, okay.
I remember because I
remember when I was like
trying to get new manga to read.
I was just like, "Fucking
hell this has 500 chapters."
I'm just like, "Oh for fuck's sake."
Right?
And then I read the first hundred chapters
in like two days and I'm
like, "Thank fucking God."
(Joey laughs)
- This has 500 chapters.
It was like one of those
manga when I'm just like-
- Yeah.
- "I'm so glad
that there is just like an
infinite number of chapters."
- It's not that that I dread,
it's that I dread that I
literally can't do anything else.
Like, I can't watch anything.
I can't read anything else.
- I love that.
I'm like that's the feeling
I'm constantly looking for.
- Yeah.
- Because I love the feeling
of just being so absorbed
into this manga or anime or something
that I literally can't
get on with my life.
Unless I'm finishing this thing.
- Yeah.
- Because like that to me is
like pure enjoyment, right?
- Yeah.
- And "Kingdom" gave me that
for like a good like month.
- I only have time.
Yeah-
- Just a month.
- I lost a month of my life, I think.
And it was like the best month ever.
It was fucking worth it.
- I only read like the
first five volumes of it.
'Cause I was like at a manga
cafe just like chilling,
waiting for a friend or whatever.
And I had to leave.
I was like, "No, I'm not leaving."
- Yeah.
- I need to continue reading.
This is fucking insane.
- Yeah, so like to give a
brief like sell of "Kingdom"-
- Yeah, sell me on "Kingdom."
- So it's like when
China was like fragmented
into different kingdoms.
- Haha, see-
- Ahh.
- You see what they did there?
- There's three kingdoms right?
- No it was, I think this one
has seven kingdoms, right.
And so it's the story of,
it's just an epic basically.
It's the very definition of an epic
where it's just the story of-
- Epic.
- So like there's one farm boy, Shin,
who's the main character.
And by complete chance,
he meets one of the future
kings of the kingdom
that he's living in, right.
And throughout the
entire history of China,
no one's been able to
unite all of the kingdoms.
No one's been able to take over everything
and just unite everyone.
And so it's very simple.
It's just the basic story of the king
growing up to be a king
and uniting everyone.
And it's the farmer who,
the farm boy who grows up
literally as a peasant, and it's his story
of becoming the greatest general of China.
- It's basically, if you
took the Golden Age arc
of "Berserk" and just made it an epic.
- Yeah.
- That sounds good.
- Which is awesome because
Golden Age arc was awesome.
(Garnt coughs)
- I love the Golden Age arc.
- Yeah, like imagine the Golden Age arc,
but the biggest to me,
the biggest selling point
of "Kingdom" is the battles.
- [Connor] This man's dying over here.
- He can't contain his love for "Kingdom."
- It went down the wrong hole.
- He's choking up thinking about it.
- Yeah I just want to
talk about "Kingdom" okay.
So I have never seen
any other piece of media
depict warfare in as much detail
as I have "Kingdom" right.
Because there's only like,
it's been 500 chapters
and one single battle
can easily take up like
50 to a hundred chapters.
- How many?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's like "Lord of the Rings."
- Yeah. I mean it's-
- Battle for Helms deep here?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Literally like imagine-
- But every battle.
- Imagine if that was
just every battle, right.
But it's fucking,
it's actually fucking insane.
Go on, go for it.
- Are we close to finishing the story?
- No.
- We're about halfway.
- Oh for fuck's sake.
See that puts me off.
Because I don't want to get into something
where I'm going to be like
50 years old and I'm like,
"Hey son, my favorite
manga is finishing soon."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- "Kingdom."
- Literally every "One Piece" fan.
- But like, it's one of those manga
where it's such a simple kind of,
it's well, it's simple
and it's not, right.
Because obviously there's a lot of,
there's a lot of like politics involved.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- There's a lot of like intricacies
into how they basically try
to take over their
kingdom because there's...
I really can't condense it down into like,
whatever I'm going to say now.
- It's an epic.
- Yeah, it is an epic.
- Oh it's epic all right.
- But like, because it's broken up
into like different arcs.
So you can just read one arc and you just,
you can just like-
- Stop.
- It's kind of-
- Take a breather.
- You can take a breather.
Like I literally binge one arc
then binge another arc and
then binge another arc.
Because I'm just like,
"I just want to see what happens
at the end of this battle."
And it depicts war, like I said,
it depicts warfare in a
better way than I've ever seen
in any other manga because like, you know,
you know how they like try
to write smart characters
in a lot of fiction, whereas
to write a smart character,
you have to make the other
character dumb, right.
So there's been so many
like warfare kind of scenes
where it's just like,
they introduce this like really
smart general or something.
And it's because he sees a strategy
that the other general doesn't see.
And like, to the reader,
it's the most obvious
fucking strategy of all time.
- We're going to go around the back.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Holy shit.
- They'll never know if we
flank them to the right.
- Yeah, exactly.
And with Kingdom, the reason it takes like
about like 50 to a hundred
chapters per battle
was because it's so-
- They're playing 5-D chess.
- They are like it's so incredible
to see so many styles of generals
battling against each other.
Because it is literally
like watching two GM's
play against each other and no,
I'm absolutely serious because like
you're turning the page and you're like,
both sides are making moves.
Both sides are like taking pieces.
They're taking rooks,
they're taking bishops.
It is kind of like watching a chess game
except because it's a battle,
it's not just all about strategy.
Sometimes you have people
who fucking flip the board
and then there's nothing
you can do about that.
Just because they're too powerful.
And then there's some people
who knows that this guy
is someone who is going to flip the board
and he takes that into account.
And so the winner of the battle,
isn't the person who's
like necessarily dumber.
It's just the person who maybe thinks
that extra half step ahead.
And you really don't know
until you turn like the
final few pages of an arc,
how it's going to turn out.
- The author must have
like fucking binge read
like "The Art Of War" like 10 times.
- Honestly.
- because like-
- Honestly, like that's it.
- I've only heard like
the most insane battles.
- I love those people that like, you know,
like those reviews.
- Yeah.
- "Sunsu five stars."
- "Come read my work."
- Like without spoiling
some of the best moments
of this manga, like I think
this manga has an arc,
which is one of my favorite
arcs of like all of manga.
- Damn.
- And that's because it's like,
it's an arc without spoiling
the exact plot points,
it's an arc where you have like
fucking five, six generals.
All of them have like I'm playing
5-D chess with each other,
making moves against each other.
And you're just like, "Holy fuck."
I can't even keep up with the
amount of strategies going on.
And the different pieces like
that are being pushed around.
It's absolutely fucking insane.
It's so big brain that
I really cannot explain.
- [Connor] I don't know.
I'm sold, I'm sold.
- Yeah and ever since I read
those five volumes of "Kingdom,"
I've been this close
to just saying fuck it.
And just buying the rest of the volumes.
- Is it published weekly?
- Mmm hmm.
- Okay, that's good. that's good.
It's published, but there's no way
they're going to get to 500 chapters.
- I've just given up hope
on manga where they're like,
"Okay, now we're publishing monthly."
And I'm like "All right."
And I'm never going to read it.
'Cause it's never going to finish.
- Yeah.
If you want to see like
the brain expands meme
of like of just reading
something that is just like
super smart without making it like seem
pretentious or something.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And the art is so good.
- I think someone asked,
I don't know who was, might
have been George RR Martin,
the question was like,
"If you're not smart,
how do you write smart characters?"
If you're not smart yourself,
how do you write a smart character?
Like, legit.
I remembered they answered something.
But even me, I was thinking about it.
Like, I don't know how you would.
How would you?
Because you wouldn't know what smart is
because you're not smart.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's I think this is
smart, is this smart?
- Is this what smart people are like?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's like-
- Ask your smart friend.
- How do you write a smart character?
Who's like 300 IQ when you're not 300 IQ.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Very good question.
- What I would guess is
that the author of this
must've just studied so many
like history, historic battles.
Because someone like the
tactics and strategies that they
come up with this, it's
just like, it's 300 IQ,
versus 302 IQ.
And it's just like,
that extra 2 IQ that gives
them the edge in battle.
- It's the pawn that matters and-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
It's such a good read.
- I'm sold, I'm sold.
- Yeah it's fucking fantastic.
- Another one to add to the fucking list.
- If you want something
that is just an incredible
epic, read "Kingdom."
- Okay.
- "Great Teacher Onizuka"-
- Classic.
- Is a classic.
- I've heard all about this.
I haven't watched it.
- It's weird.
I've never read the manga for this.
I've only watched the anime.
- [Connor] I've hear the
anime is amazing though.
- Yeah.
The anime is amazing.
But I've heard the manga is even better.
- I think the anime is, I mean,
it's good because the
manga is fucking amazing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right, that's the only
reason the anime is good.
- The recipe so god damn good
you can't mess up (indistinct).
(Joey laughs)
- Because like you, okay.
Have you seen the anime?
- I've seen the anime yeah.
- When do you think it came out?
- What, the anime?
- Yeah.
- It was like late eighties, right?
Wasn't it?
- It came out in the year 2000.
(Connor laughs)
I'm not joking.
- Are you serious?
- I am serious.
- That was like a trap question.
I felt the trap when he asked that.
- It feels like late 80's manga.
- It feels like late 80's-
- Early 90's manga.
- It feels like late 80's,
early 90's, anime adaptation.
- Yeah.
- It came out in the 2000's.
It came out after "Cowboy Bebop."
- I'm so lost.
- But because like,
because the anime adaptation-
- I wasn't expecting to
have an existential crisis
over GTO today, God damn.
- So, I mean, I think I've
talked about GTO briefly before.
But to give a brief synopsis of GTO,
it's about this teacher
who is a delinquent.
- Oh, he great.
- Oh great.
- Oh, he a great teacher.
- He's...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He's not a great teacher yet
because he's just....
So his name is Onizuka.
And he's delinquent who finds himself
in a teaching job, right?
- Let me guess, let me guess.
He's just, he's not a
good teacher in the start.
But he learns to love the kids
and he wants to help the kids.
So he becomes a good
teacher along the way.
- No, actually he wants
to be the greatest teacher
in all of Japan.
Hence the name:
- "Great Teacher Onizuka."
- But he's given like a very
problematic class, right.
And yeah, he's not like the
greatest teacher academically.
And that's like part of
the point of this manga
is that he doesn't teach academic lessons.
He teaches life lessons.
And I know sounds-
- How do I reach these kids?
- He ain't book smart.
He's street smart.
- This is how you wear bag kids,
making you shoulder it correctly.
- But like it's a manga that
I think really affected me
when I read this as like a teenager,
because you know, it is like
a completely cheesy kind
of setup, right.
Because you know, it's just,
"Oh, it's a teacher who
reforms a problematic classroom
and teaches them life lessons.
It makes them appreciate life and stuff."
And yeah, that's exactly it.
It's probably the best feel
good manga I've ever read.
- Japan loves those
kinds of mangas though.
There's another manga like
that called "Rookies."
I don't know if you know that one.
- I don't.
- It's like if you took GTO
but you made them play baseball.
And, but it's like, it's
the exact same, like,
feel good vibe.
You have the delinquent teacher
who like teaches a bunch of
delinquents to like join a baseball team
and stuff like that.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Exact same feel as GTO.
It's like just as good.
- It's just, it's just really,
it's also a comedy one.
And I do like the comedy, but like,
what I really love is that, you know,
it doesn't teach you so much
cheesy life lessons, right?
It's so much, it's just
teaches you that you,
especially growing up in Asian culture,
it tries to teach you that, you know,
grades and you're like
this, the school system,
isn't what defines you as a person.
And I feel like a lot of
people might need to like hear
some of the things that
this manga has to say.
- Especially in Japan.
And especially in Asian culture.
And kind of the cherry on
top is just how fucking goofy
and at the same time bad ass Onizuka is.
I fucking, seeing the
antics they put him through
is just like everything is such a treat.
Like one of my favorite
scenes in the manga,
which never got adapted
to the anime was like,
he was trying to teach
this like this leader
of like this gang to
like try to attend school
and take it fucking
seriously and all that shit.
And so this guy, this student leads him
to like this underground,
like fight ring or something.
I can't remember the exact
setup, but he's just like,
"Look, if I arm wrestle
a hundred of you and win,
then you got to come to school."
And it's just like,
this is so fucking stupid, right.
Because it's just like,
how are you going to fucking
arm wrestle a hundred people.
And then he, he beats one person.
He beats two persons.
He beat...
He starts taking on three at a time.
And like-
- Three at a time?
- Yeah, yeah.
He starts taking on three at a time.
It's Shonen manga okay.
And he's just like,
the way that it just kind of builds up
and like escalates is
like hilarious and bad-ass
at the same time.
- Yeah.
- And it's, it's something
where it's not 100% serious,
but when it hits, it fucking hits.
And some like,
it's a manga that can really,
I wouldn't say change a person, but it...
If you're looking for
something that affects you
in the opposite way of "Punpun."
Where it's just like, "Wow"-
- It uses comedy to teach you.
- Yeah.
- Not depression.
- Yeah, it still teaches you
like very important life lessons,
but you feel wholesome at the day.
You don't want to cry.
- I feel like that genre of manga
is so like beloved and known and quite,
you know, more common, especially
to a Japanese audience.
I feel it's slept on in the West.
- Really?
- Like there are so many like good,
like feel-good comedy centered,
like delinquent life lesson
type of manga that is out there.
And they're all fucking great.
- Yeah because, I feel like
to do this type of manga,
or to do this type of story,
it's so hard to just not be cheesy.
- Yeah, true.
- You know, like.
And I feel like GTO is that one manga
when I'm just like you see
this done in any other way
and it would just be cheesy.
But, the way that they do
it in this, just it doesn't-
- It almost doesn't take
itself seriously always.
- Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
So, yeah, Onizuka like,
I think one of my favorite
characters in manga
for that reason.
What'd you want to go on next?
- Can we talk about "Psyren?"
- Okay.
- Why is "Psyren?"
- What is "Psyren?"
What the fuck is that?
- Shonen Jump.
- It's Shonen Jump.
I'm surprised you've heard of "Psyren."
- I fucking love "Psyren."
- You love "Psyren."
Oh my fucking God, yes!
- That's why I was like,
"Why is this here?"
- What is "Psyren?"
- It's one of those,
like, it's one of those-
- Please explain the plot.
- Underground Shonen Jump manga that like-
- Okay.
- It didn't have very
long run time, did it?
- I mean, it had like a
good hundred chapters.
- Did it?
- It got canceled.
It got canceled.
- That's right.
Yeah it did get canceled.
- [Connor] All right so, tell the plot.
- I will tell you the plot.
Okay, so there's going to
be like a slight spoiler,
but I feel like it's within
the first four chapters.
And I feel like it's a big twist
that I feel is what got me
hooked into this manga, right.
So, that's the main...
I can't actually remember
the character names.
'Cause it's been so
long since I've read it.
- Yeah, yeah.
But it's this main character and he,
I don't think there's
anything too special about him
at the beginning.
He runs a service where
he solves problems, right.
That's got nothing to do
with what happens, right.
And so he sees this girl, it looks like
she looks like she's going
through some issues or something.
So she, he tries to help her.
And in that process,
he follows her and then he
gets transported with her
to just this new place.
He doesn't know where he is, right.
- He gets Isakai'd.
- Yeah, he basically gets Isakai'd, right.
- So goes to another world.
- Yeah, yeah, kind of.
He goes to another world.
- Ooh I see a theme here Garnt.
- Yeah, no.
He goes to another world
with this girl, right.
And then they're in, just in,
there's just in this
like barren wasteland.
And then they get transported
with a bunch of people.
And it's kinda like the
"Gantz" kind of theme
where it's not as brutal.
'Cause it's like Shonen Jump "Gantz."
So it's not got like massive gore,
but like people just start
dying left, right, and center.
- [Connor] Okay.
- Right.
And for some reason she has
like a special psychic power
that she uses to survive.
So he kind of follows her right.
And so in like fighting through
this kind of "death game",
kind of barren wasteland kind of thing,
he like tries to figure
out where the fuck he is,
how he got there and what
the fuck's going on, right.
And then it's like the big
twist at the end of episode four
is that he goes on top
of this like a building
that's just been like, laying,
it's like a, what's the
word I'm looking for?
- Like abandoned or-
- No, not abandoned, but
it's just like, it's,
what's the word where it's just like,
it's been years since
this building's been-
- Overgrown?
- Dilapidated?
- Dilapidated, yeah.
It's this dilapidated building right.
And he, and he goes on it
and then he sees Mount Fuji, right.
And it's just, he realizes
that for some reason, he's in Japan.
He's in a city that is in complete ruins
and the apocalypse has happened.
And so he doesn't know how
he got there or where he is.
- That's right.
- Or, should I say it?
Okay, I'm going to say it, okay-
- Spoiler alert.
- Or when he is, but-
- I mean, I guessed when you
had said that he was in Japan
that is was a time thing.
- When he said it was dilapidated.
- Yeah, I was like okay well
that's a signal the passage of time.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, I guess that spoils it.
But yeah, I mean, so
what I love about this
is that it's a Shonen Jump action manga
that has a mystery core.
Because the core of this is
him going back to his own world
or his own time and kind of figuring out
what the fuck happened.
How did it happen?
And in that process, like,
that's all I'm going to say,
because in that process,
there's so many twists and
turns that come from that
and him trying to figure
out what's going on.
And it was just nice to
see like a Shonen Jump
that has action in it,
but also has this really mystery aspect
that keeps you coming back
and just keeps you like
reading the next page
just to figure out what happens.
Because I feel like
there's been Shonen Jump
with a mystery aspect, for example,
what's the one where they eat kids, again?
- "Promise Neverland."
It's a bit like "Promise Neverland"
and it's a bit like, obviously-
- I've never heard "Promise Neverland"
be described as "what's the
one where they eat kids?"
- I mean, am I wrong?
- I don't know why I got it right away.
- Am I wrong, am I wrong?
- I mean-
- That is what happens.
- That is what it is, that is what it is.
- It's not the one about
the kids trying to escape.
It is the one where the kids get eaten.
- Don't fuck around.
- Like I liked the fact
that it had a mystery aspect
and also a battle Shonen aspect.
And I feel like it was so underground.
'Cause nobody fucking read it.
- I think the problem with "Psyren"
is that it kind of came out
at a time where Shonen Jump
was just absolutely stacked.
Where like everything else in Shonen-
'Cause this was like mid
2000's Shonen Jump, right?
So this was not only in
the midst of the Big Three,
but also like the lesser
known Shonen Jump stuff
that was not the Big Three
was still very, very popular.
- So why did they get canceled?
- Just because it wasn't popular enough.
- It just got axed.
- I'm just like,
I feel like another thing
is that unfortunately
the art style just looks so generic
because this came after "Bleach."
- It does look...
The main character looks like Ichigo.
- Yeah, yeah.
It kind of looks so generic,
but it has so many original ideas.
Like I've really liked without spoiling
what the main character's power is.
So like anyone who goes to this world
gets a special power of their own, right.
And I like as an engineer,
he has like a really unique power
where I'm not going to
spoil exactly what it is,
but he can't control this power.
Like he can't consciously
control this power.
So what he does to kind of
figure out a way different ways
to use his power is he makes
sub routines for this power.
So it's basically like he
makes programming loops
for this power, like to
follow a set algorithm,
to do exactly what he wants.
- That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like,
"That's such a unique idea."
- I'm like slowly, remembering this manga
as you talk about it.
- Man can type 2000 words per minute.
(Garnt laughs)
- But yeah, like, I mean, I could-
- Sounds interesting.
- I could have put like "Hunter x Hunter"
or other Shonen jump manga on here.
- It's nice to see some variation.
- But yeah, like I said,
every Shonen Jump manga I
can think of putting on here
has an anime adaptation.
So that's the only reason why
I put "Psyren" on here
because it is my favorite
Shonen Jump manga
that does not have an anime.
Because it got canceled because
it wasn't popular enough.
- The other one I would
put it on there is...
Gid you ever read "M Zero?"
- I did not read "M Zero."
- Okay that's another one
that was like, kind of,
it came out around the
same time as "Psyren"
where Shonen Jump was just stacked.
Never gotten an anime
adaptation, but it's so good.
- What's that about?
- "M Zero" is about...
It's basically it's this kid
who enters this magic school,
but he himself has zero magic abilities.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So this is literally like,
think of like fucking
"My Hero Academia" right?
Where instead of quirks it's magic power.
And you have like certain levels of magic.
And the higher your magic level is,
the more powerful of
like a magic card you get
that can like activate magic
skills and the main character,
again, he has zero magic
so he gets an M Zero card.
- Ahh okay.
- And it's just him basically just trying
to basically survive and
graduate the magic school.
But like the art style is so unique
and it's such a dope, solid story.
But again, it never got
an anime adaptation.
And like hardly anyone
read it, because again-
- Did it get canceled?
- Shonen Jump.
No, it didn't get canceled.
It had a proper ending, it got
like 12 volumes of something.
- [Connor] Oh.
- And it had a proper ending.
It just no one read it
because during that time,
Shonen Jump was so stacked.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- With all these other insane shows-
- It's stacked now as well.
- It's stacked now
but like mid 2000's
Shonen Jump was like peak.
- So you can recommend it even
though there's not an ending?
- Oh no, it has an ending.
It's just very rushed.
But like-
- They were like wrap it up, come on.
- "Yu Yu Hakusho" was
kind of the same as well.
- Yeah, but like, I feel like
I can still recommend it.
Because the mystery aspect got solved
and it got solved in a
decent amount of time.
What didn't get...
What was like a bit unsatisfying
was just each character's resolution
because it got wrapped up so quickly.
But the mystery aspect,
which was the reason I was so
addicted to it, and reading,
that gets wrapped up just fine.
And that's why I can still recommend it.
- So, what's "Love Hina" about?
- Wait, have you not read
or watch "Love Hina?"
- No, I don't-
- Really?
- I don't know anything about "Love Hina."
- Wow.
- "Love Hina"-
- It's about...
- I'mma say right now.
This is nostalgia.
- I mean look, Akamatu
Ken's fucking amazing.
- It is.
- "Love Hina" is a classic.
- Listen explain yourself.
What is it about?
- It's nothing you haven't heard before.
- It's a manga where a guy loves Hina.
- Oh for fuck's sake.
(Garnt laughs)
- That's Hina.
- Is it interesting?
- And he loves Hina.
- That's Naru.
- Oh yeah.
- That's Naru and...
Okay, so a guy moves
in to his grandma's onsen, right?
Because his grandma owns owns an onsen
and it turns out it's also
a girls' dormitory and-
(Connor sighs)
- Ayeee.
- Okay, all right.
- And okay, it's a
fucking harem anime okay.
It's a, sorry, it's a harem manga okay.
- Okay, okay.
- And how can I say this?
- It's a classic isn't it.
- It's it's it's just a solid harem manga.
And there's nothing I can do
to convince you to watch it.
I'm not going to try and
convince you to read it, okay.
I'm not here.
This isn't for you, Connor.
This is for me.
This is for me Connor.
- I never said it was. You know-
- This is Garnt's "Ichigo 100%."
- Honestly, this was the very
first manga I have ever read.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Out of everything, right?
'Cause I remember watching...
it was the first anime I ever watched
because before that I had this like-
- First anime?
- No, sorry.
It's the first anime I-
- I was going to say
this is the first anime
you ever watched?
- This is the first anime I watched
where before that I had
this massive complex
against manga, right?
'Cause I was like, no, because like-
- I discriminated against manga.
- Honestly, honestly, because I'm like,
"How can you get into
black and white drawings?
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
This is disgusting.
This is for peasants."
- Western comics go through
the trouble of coloring in.
- Where's the movement?
- Where's the color?
- Exactly, that's what I'm saying.
- I'm just like, "How am I
supposed to get into this?"
And unlike "Love Hina" was
the first anime I watch
where I'm just like, "I
want to see what happens."
- I'll fight through the black and white.
- And I want to see what happens enough,
that I'll fucking read the manga.
- She looks cute, but she
looks like a Pokemon reject.
(Joey laughs)
- She's a-
- I think every character in the 90's
looked like a Pokemon reject.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's true.
- Because I think they all
had like the same kind of characteristics.
- So out of 10?
- I mean, I-
- Just give me a fucking score Garnt.
What is it?
- 10.
- Oh fuck off.
(Garnt laughs)
- That stutter was a 5.
That served the ending enough.
- I think "Love Hina" to this day
is like a solid six or seven.
- It's just a fun six or seven?
- It's a fun manga.
- If you like harem manga-
- No.
- Which you don't.
So if you like harem manga,
I still think "Love Hina" is such,
is a very, very solid harem manga.
- It still stands up to it's time.
- Why do you love harem
anime and manga so much?
I mean what about the
harem speaks to you Garnt?
- I just like girls.
(Connor laughs)
- I want all the girls.
- I'll break it down
because this is going to
be a really weird analogy.
If I'm like,
if there's a harem manga
that I'm invested in,
it's not, it's not specifically about,
oh, there's a bunch of girls.
What I equates reading a harem manga to,
it's kind of like watching
a sports match, right?
Because like-
- I knew you were going
fucking to say that.
- Yeah, yeah, because...
Okay, because-
- You pick your team
when you root for them.
and you get emotionally invested, right?
- Yeah.
- And you pick your best girl
and you fucking root for them.
And you stick through it
through thick and thin.
- Yup.
- And then-
- Even if they don't win,
they've won in your heart.
- Yeah, even if they don't
win, but if they do win-
- It's like, "Yeah!"
- It's such an emotional rush.
'Cause you're like, "Yes, yes, yes!"
You literally become a fucking sports fan.
- I bet Garnt's never as happy
as when his fucking harem of choice wins.
- Honestly like, part of the
best part of harems, right,
Is being, is watching
it with the community.
Because like half the fun
is seeing your girl win.
But also half the fun
is shitting on the fans
of the losing girls as well.
- Yeah.
- That's like, that's like equally as fun.
- That's what I loved about "Ichigo 100%"
because I read it with a
bunch of my Japanese friends
who are all just as invested.
And the all had their own winners.
And when I, when my girl won, I was like,
"Fuck you!
I told you!"
- Joey had the biggest dick that week.
- I did, I did.
I felt good, I felt good.
- All right. Okay. I mean-
- So like, I mean, I still
think it's a solid harem.
I think one of the biggest differences
to a lot of harems I met
is that I do like the
character development
of the main guy.
He starts off as obviously a fucking loser
with no personality.
But as the series goes
on, he actually develops.
- Why do we ever get Chad's
as the main characters.
- Because they wouldn't be interesting.
- Because then it wouldn't be a hentai.
- Chad should become more-
- That's the difference between-
- More Chad?
- Where's the space for growth
if they're already a Chad.
- Maybe they come more modest.
Maybe they learn modesty.
- No one wants to see that.
- I wanna see a man learn modesty.
- He goes from like this
brick shit house brute.
- It's just the guy who
was too full of himself.
And he just gets modest.
I'd watch that.
That'd be awesome.
- I'm sure that exists somewhere.
- And I guess like the
other classic on there,
of course is "20th Century Boys."
- I thought you were going
to say "Domestic Girlfriend."
- Yeah, I thought you
were about to say "Domestic Girlfriend."
(Garnt laughs)
- I was about to like
give you the back hand.
- While we're on shit,
let's keep talking about
"Domestic Girlfriend."
If we're going to talk about "Love Hina."
- [Garnt] Okay, okay. okay.
I realize-
- He's not going to stop talking you know.
- Just give me.
We've seen it on your channel.
- Yeah.
- We can and watch it.
- We've seen your videos.
- We can literally go
and get the fountain of
like nonexistent youth
from you on this thing
where you just never age
and you talk about this for 10 years.
- I can continually talk about it.
- I don't want to.
Give me a five minute...
You've got 5 minutes Garnt.
- Sell this to me because-
- You have five minutes.
- I watched three episodes
and I immediately dropped it.
- "Domestic Girlfriend" fucking
awoke something in me man.
(Joey laughs)
- Like this single show
basically dictated my
hentai taste from like-
- [Connor] So, so, so, so-
- There's me before "Domestic Girlfriend"
and there's me after
"Domestic Girlfriend."
- So wait, if I'm correct is it,
there's a guy and there's a teacher?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And a sister.
- Okay, okay, okay, so-
- That's correct?
Is that correct?
- Okay, so let me break
it down for you okay.
So there's this guy who has,
who's in love with his teacher, right?
And one day he just
randomly goes up to a meetup
and he meets another girl at a karaoke.
What's it called?
In like a-
- Bar? Bar?
- [Producer] A bar?
- No what's the event where-
- [Sydney] A mixer.
- A mixer.
Thank you Sydney, you know.
So he goes to a mixer.
And he meets this girl.
And this girl for some reason
wants to lose her virginity.
Because she just at that
age where she just like,
"Fuck it, I've got nothing better to do."
- Doesn't the anime literally
open with them like-
- Yeah.
- After having sex.
- The anime literally opens
with them just after sex.
- [Connor] Okay, right.
- And so he sleeps with this girl
and then, who he's just
met and they say goodbye.
And then he goes home.
And then he finds out that
his dad's getting remarried.
And then he meets the family
that he's getting like,
his dad's getting married to.
And it turns out that the mother of,
or his future mother-in-law,
or no his future step-mother.
She has two daughters.
One is the girl he slept with
and the other is the
teacher he's in love with.
And that is the premise
of "Domestic Girlfriend."
- Where is the incest
sign when we need it?
- This is literally, this is incest Garnt.
And this is just like,
this is like what if we made
all porn categories into one.
This is what it sounds like.
- Basically.
- This is like combine every porn.
Where are the laundry machines?
Get four of them in this house.
(Joey laughs)
- Okay, so like I will fully admit that-
- This is porn.
- The concept...
I mean, yeah this is a hentai plot.
- This is your "Kiss Sis."
(everyone laughs)
- Let's be real, it is.
- No, no.
It's better than "Kiss Sis."
- It is.
- People would want...
Like when we did the anime three-by-three,
people were like, "Why is the
'Domestic Girlfriend 'anime
not on there?"
It's because I actually read the manga.
I think it's a good fucking manga
and I will defend it til
the day I fucking die.
- Would you say it's a masterpiece?
- I would say-
(everyone laughs)
- I'm asking.
- It's a masterpiece in my heart.
- Okay, I understand.
- No because like, what happens is like-
- If masterpiece is short for
masturbating piece then yes.
- But like, what I love about this manga
is that it takes the most like,
the situation is a complete car wreck.
And it just turns to a
car wreck to a train wreck
to a fucking nuclear Holocaust.
Like the layers of how
complicated the situation gets
just gets stacked on top of each other.
But what offsets this
is that it's actually a
really well written manga.
It's like a lot of thought-
- Hold on, you're being very
oxymoronic right now, okay.
- Okay, okay.
Because a lot of thought was
really put into the characters.
So the characters actually
seem really realistic
and you can kind of like
empathize with them, right?
What you can't relate to
is the fucking situation that they're in.
So you put really-
- I hope not.
- You put actual like realistic characters
or well written characters
into this really fucking
trashy, wacky situation.
And it's like a juxtaposition
of just you're actually
invested in these characters,
but also the stuff that's
happening is so wild
that you just want to keep reading
just to see what happens next.
It's like a soap opera,
but the characters are
actually really like,
you're really, really
invested in these characters.
- I just couldn't get to
that point with the anime.
Honestly, I was like-
- No, no, no-
- So what's more of a
battle, this or "Kingdom?"
What's more of an epic battle?
- That's two different battle, isn't it?
- Which is the bigger battle?
- I don't know which
one's more five head man.
- One of them is like,
you're physically getting hurt battle
and the other is like
chipping away your brain.
- Okay because like the
anime is the really...
Okay, what the anime
did is that it just took
all the trashy moments in the manga
without any of the character moments
and just put them and just speed run it.
- So, they made a bad porno.
- Huh?
- They made a bad porno.
- Yeah, they made a bad porno.
- Okay.
- I mean, what porno doesn't
have character development.
Well how can I get invested?
- Most of them.
- A good one.
We don't need it.
- And yeah, I will keep talking
about "Domestic Girlfriend"-
- I'm sure if you want to
hear Garnt talk about it,
just ask him in public, ask him anywhere.
- Watch the 17 videos he made on it.
- I realize that I've made
like a manga three-by-three,
a hentai three-by-three,
a dojin three-by-three.
- This is all in one.
- And an anime three-by-three.
And all of them have incest in it.
I just want to say for the record-
- Where is the incest
sign when we need it?
- I just want to say for the
record, I do not like incest-
- You are very lucky
you are an only child.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- That's all I'm saying.
Otherwise the incest
would've destroyed you.
- Yeah.
- If I put this many
incest things in mine,
everyone would be like, "Yo
Connor's got three brothers.
Oh no."
- I've got a sister.
And I'd be fucked.
- Look, all I'm saying is at
least I don't like stepmom porn
because everyone has a mother.
What like everyone, everyone,
everyone has a mother.
What's your excuse?
What's your excuse Connor for mothers.
"Mother Knows Breasts."
- Let's not get into that.
- All right, let's let's talk
about "20th Century Boys."
- Okay.
- Because that is actually a good manga.
- Okay this is my favorite
manga of all time.
- It's brilliant.
- I've never read this.
I've been wanting to read this.
I've actually got it
downloaded, ready to read.
- Everything by Urasawa Naoki is-
- Oh, I can give you the
manga volumes instead.
- Oh you have them with you?
- Yeah that's-
- In English?
- Yeah in English.
- Oh sick.
- That's a much better-
- What other language is
he going to read it in?
- Thai, I don't know.
The cover look bad ass.
- Well, yeah.
It's fucking amazing.
- So "20th Century Boys" is
my favorite manga of all time.
And I only read this just
before moving to Japan
and it's kind of like the "Oyuamsi Punpun"
where I knew I would love this for ages.
And I held off reading it
until I had just the right amount of time
and the right mindset.
And that just so happens when
I had the few week break,
before I moved to Japan.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, "Okay, I
am now ready to experience
'20th Century Boys'."
- I am now ready for emotions.
- Yeah, and it lived up
to everything and more.
I like, I knew it was like a
magnum opus of a piece of work.
- Yeah.
- And I still like, it's amazing.
But also it like every
lesson and every message
you tried to say, like spoke
to me personally as well.
So it was kind of like
a mixture of personally,
this was my kind of story,
and also it's an amazing story.
- This was the manga that made me go,
"Wow Urasaw Naoki is a fucking genius."
- Can you give me a very
quick rundown of the plot.
- Sure, sure.
Okay, it's so-
- Because I don't really
know anything about it.
- It's, I'll-
- It's a pretty convoluted plot isn't it?
- Its a very-
- Just give me the most
bare bones explanation.
- Okay, so I'll try to sell you
this as quickly as possible.
So imagine like when you're
growing up as a kid, right,
you play hero and villains, right?
And so like you play a hero
and someone plays the hero
and someone plays the villain.
And normally a super villain,
they try to take over the world, right?
It's a cartoony plot.
They take over the world
and the hero stops them.
Now, what if you could
make this very childish plot believable?
That is basically what "20th
Century Boys" is, right.
- Sounds cool.
- It's someone who basically
tries to take over the world
and Naoki Urusaw went, "How
can we actually make this
actually seem realistic and feasible?"
- And terrifying.
- And terrifying as well.
That's like the bare bones,
basic premise of this.
What I love about this is that
it's kind of like a mystery.
So it doesn't open up with that premise.
What it opens up with is this guy,
who's just a normal guy who stumbles
upon a conspiracy, right?
And so of course,
if you stumble upon a
conspiracy and you see
how deep this conspiracy goes.
- The Earth is flat.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
And the way the story
unravels is that like
you are given pieces just
to how deep this conspiracy,
this conspiracy goes and how far it runs.
And the more chapters that you read,
normally, like you see a mystery
and like you you're able to like,
kind of get a feel for like
how big this mystery is, right.
What I find fucking amazing
about "20th Century Boys",
is that I was like five to 10 volumes in
or something like that.
And it felt like I was
staring into an abyss
in terms of this mystery, like,
this feeling where you
just don't know how deep
this rabbit hole goes.
Like you are just like,
"There's no way this can go deeper."
And then something gets revealed.
And you're like,
"Where does this end?"
- [Connor] What the fuck?
- How the fuck?
How far does this go?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And like, the way that,
and I find that incredible.
There's no been no other mystery
that's just given me this
feeling of just like,
it was kind of like
almost existential dread.
Because I know how far this
sank or how deep this went.
And it's probably like, it's
my favorite manga of all time.
I think it's my favorite
mystery of all time.
- Urasawa Naoki is just
so amazing at writing
these just mysteries where it's just like
you don't know where it's going.
And also, I don't know about you,
but Urasawa Naoki I feel is a genius
at writing some of the
most perfect antagonists-
- Yeah, yeah.
- In manga, I mean, he also did "Monster."
- Oh.
Okay you should've said that.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
It's the same guy.
- Same guy writing "Monster."
- Okay I'm sold.
I'm sold.
- But like "Monster" is like
way more character-driven
and I think it's like
much more smaller scale.
This one is like a fucking massive scale.
- This fucking sucks.
I've got so much to read now.
Fuck.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I'm this is never going
to get anime adaptation.
- No.
- Because like, compared to "Monster"-
- It go a live action though.
- This is, yeah-
- It did?
- Yeah, it's shit.
- It's shit.
I mean, compared to "Monster",
this would be like
hundreds of episodes maybe.
- Oh yeah.
- Because that's just,
that's just how, like far-
- "Monster" was like
70 something episodes.
This would easily be
like 150-200 episodes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm down.
Make it happen.
"Hunter x Hunter" got over 148.
- True.
- Yeah.
And yeah, I feel like
it's the greatest manga
I've ever read and-
- It's definitely up there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is there anything more than that?
Can you give it higher praise than that?
I guess I to read it.
- [Joey] You have to read it.
- Oh fuck me.
- [Joey] Yeah it's brilliant.
- It's my, I like,
I can't even pick a
favorite anime of all time,
but the fact that I can pick
a favorite manga of all time-
- Is telling.
- That's telling.
- Ladies and gentlemen.
- We got him.
- And it's not "Domestic Girlfriend."
Surprisingly.
- Thank fuck for that.
- Even though it's in the middle.
(Joey laughs)
I didn't put anything
significant in my middle one.
I just clicked.
I should have, I should have.
- It was the Oromo square.
That's why I put it in the middle.
- And do you have, well, two more?
Well, I guess one more.
We'll talk about "Berserk" after.
"Beck."
- Yeah.
- The manga for "Beck."
- I've only watched the anime.
- You've only watched the anime?
- Joey, Joey.
- Joey my boy.
- I know-
- You would actually
love the "Beck" manga.
- I mean dude I fucking loved the anime.
And again, same thing.
Everyone's saying the
manga is even better.
- The manga is even better.
- Before you get your dicks
out and start comparing them,
walk me through the plot of "Beck."
I know nothing.
- I mean, it's like a...
It's a music anime right.
- Music.
- Fuck off.
It's not a music anime.
- It is a music anime.
- Just music?
- Yup.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He just plays music?
- He just joins a band
and tries to get big.
- Yeah, so-
- Come on, come on.
Fuck off.
- I'm not even joking.
- That's it?
- I'm not joking.
- That's it.
- That's literally the plot of "Beck."
- What's good about it then?
- It's just the journey.
- It's completely character driven.
- You looked at me dead
in the eyes and just said,
"It's the journey."
- Well it's just like some-
- It really is the journey.
- It's the journey.
The journey.
- I mean, it is.
Like it's...
What I love about "Beck,"
I mean, it's a very simple
story in that sense.
It's a complete character driven story
where it's about a boy who joins a band
and they're very underground.
They're trying to make it big.
And it's literally just their journey
of making it big, right.
And you know, I mean you've seen movies
and fucking, you know, stories-
- "A Star is Born."
- Huh?
- Yeah, and obviously
there's, I mean, there's-
- "Sabrina."
- Miley Cyrus, Hannah Montana.
- The best of both worlds.
- Sorry, sorry.
- Think about that but just like better.
(all laugh)
- How dare you diss my Miley like that.
- It's just a good musical anime?
- It is just the most-
- Does it just relies on
the characters is that.
- Oh, it's very heavily
reliant on the characters.
But like the way the characters
are written and just the,
how they like play off each
other and like all the, I mean,
A, it's very realistic,
which is already like a big plus for me,
especially with like a character
driven story like that.
But also just like, yeah, I don't know.
It's just a really good journey.
- Do you think I'd enjoy it?
- Ah, do you like rock music?
- I enjoy rock music.
- I mean, it's if you were like...
To me "Beck"-
- I feel like Mark Zuckerberg
answering that question.
"Do you like human things?
Yes I like human things."
- Initiate blink.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
- I kind of realized,
I asked the person who enjoys
the beeps and the boobs.
- I do-
- Do you like rock music?
- I do enjoy rock music.
But I felt like the pressure
was on for some reason.
Sorry, go ahead.
- Yeah. I mean,
it's what I love about
"Beck" is that it's just all,
it just captures the, you know,
the love for rock and you
know, good old, you know,
old classic rock and roll.
And just like how rock
has evolved through time.
- So they mentioned like all of like,
do they mention the fact,
like they play like a cover of the Beatles
and shit like that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh okay.
That's dope.
- Wait, how does, is it, you know?
'Cause I just thought, wait a second.
I'm like, "Oh wait.
Surely you'd want to listen to the music."
- Yeah, so I thought that-
- That's why I watched the anime.
- Yeah that's what I figured.
- I thought that as well, right.
Because I was just like,
"Shit I kind of really
want to know what happens,
but I don't know if I can get it invested
in a fucking manga about music where..."
I don't know if you'd
know anything about manga,
but you can't really hear anything
that's going on in the manga.
- That shit don't have audio.
- [Garnt] Yeah, and then then
I realized the fucking...
I kind of realized a super life hack
when reading "Beck," right.
Because you know, I
also watched the anime.
That's what got me into reading the manga.
- I know what you're going to say.
And I realized that when they're playing
in their concerts and it's hype.
- You play the song?
- You can literally
just play whatever song
you fucking love and you
feel the fucking emotion.
- Mega brain.
- Fucking brain expansion.
- Brain expansion.
- That sounds like a lot of work you know.
I've got to go through my playlist.
- Brain expansion.
- I mean like you can do it if you,
if you want to like really get invested
and really like put yourself
into this rock concert.
But what what's amazing
about the manga is that
it somehow captures the energy
of a concert so fucking well.
And like if you've ever been to a gig
and if you've ever like seen,
- Sorry, sorry Garnt.
- Thanks.
Thank you Connor, thank you.
No I'm joking, I'm joking.
- I was just so bored.
(everyone laughs)
I'm kidding.
- I sneeze when I'm bored.
- Connor when he listens to
someone talking about music.
- He's having like
allergic reaction to it.
He's like music-
(mocks sneeze)
- Sorry, someone like read
musical sheets near me.
Go on, go on.
- If you've ever been to a gig
and especially like a rock concert,
there's a certain like energy-
- [Connor] I agree.
- To seeing your favorite bands live.
And I don't know how the manga,
which is a medium where
you can't hear anything,
it captures the energy so well
that you can play the music
of whatever your favorite band is.
And you're just like, "Holy
fuck, I'm feeling hyped."
And the reason this is-
- It's more about conveying the feelings
than the music necessarily.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And the music is just like
kind of like complementary
to that as well.
And like, if you like the anime, Joey,
then you're going to
fucking love the manga.
Because the manga takes the best parts
of like the best scenes of
what happens in the anime.
And there are scenes in the manga
that are like five times as hype
as anything that happens
in "Grateful Sounds."
- I know when I'm buying next.
- I guess you're sold.
- Yeah, yeah.
Like, it's hard to sell "Beck"
if you haven't seen the anime.
Because if you haven't seen the anime,
I think that's the best
way to get into the manga.
- Yeah.
- Because it's, like I said,
it's a musical manga
and it might be a hard sell
if you don't know what
you're getting into.
- So give just it a shot?
- But if you like rock, if
you like good old rock n roll-
- I still remember that scene in "Beck"
that made me be like hell yeah.
It was like the scene
where he does the cover
of "I got a Feeling" by the Beatles.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That scene is like the most
fucking like hell yes moment.
- Fucking incredible moment.
- It is so good.
- I don't know what you're talking about-
- [Joey] It's so good.
- But hell yes.
Hell yes.
- It's just so steeped in rock culture.
- Yeah.
- That if you like that-
- There's a lot of people in Japan
just love fucking rock n' roll.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- People say, you know, when
you see a British, like,
"Oh Sex Pistols.
Yeah, yeah, that's me."
- That's a British fan.
- Honestly, like they
make so many references
to like real life bands.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Which is something I also love as well.
- Yeah.
- Like they say like, "Oh,
this person's inspired
by Hendricks or Sex Pistols."
- I think there's another
manga that does that.
- "Jojo."
- Yeah "Jojo."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Exactly right?
- That was the joke I was going to go for.
Joey fucking stole it.
- And of course, the only
square that's been taken up
by all three of our
three-by-threes, "Berserk."
- Rightfully deserved.
- The legend has arrived.
I think last time we spoke about it,
I don't think I'd finished
it on the podcast, had I?
- No you hadn't.
- No I don't think so.
- Well I "finished it".
- You caught up to it.
- Yeah I caught up.
But I mean, you could
tell it was nearly done.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It kind of had like its
own somewhat conclusion.
- Kind of.
- Around that point.
- I mean, when I was reading
it and I saw the dreaded,
I saw how many chapters
I had left, you know,
the little sinking feeling
was coming in my heart,
but you know, I still, I'm very sad.
'Cause I felt like he
was so close to the end.
Like we were, we were there,
like he was literally prepping.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- He was prepping.
He was in the praying phase.
- I think, I still think he had a lot.
- I don't know because he you know,
you know how before a big raid, you know,
you get some new armor,
you get some new stuff, right.
That's what was going on.
- That was definitely a
prominent fight coming for sure.
- We were going to, and it was
gearing up that it was like,
all right, we're getting a big boy fight.
- Yeah.
- Yeah yeah.
- It might've been like 10
years away, but it was coming.
- It was coming.
It was on its way.
- It was like, "Oh she coming."
- And I'm like, do we need
to re-exaplain the plot of "Berserk?"
Do we?
- I mean it's just-
- I guess we should a little bit, right?
If you haven't read "Berserk."
There's probably people watching this
who have not read
"Berserk" because I mean,
I was one of the people.
- Would you like to explain the plot then?
- There was a boy who was orphaned.
He was thrown to the wayside
in a pile of horrible
fluids on the ground.
And there was a woman who was like,
"No, we must pick this up."
And the mercenary band that was traveling
with this woman, was like,
"No, let him let him die."
But then somehow the woman
convinces the men to let her
pick the baby up and raise this child
who is going to be Guts,
our main character.
And as you can tell, this
upbringing is not the best
and many more horrible things happen
to this child through his upbringing.
- So may horrible things.
- So many gross things.
But the band of mercenaries
also train him to be a warrior.
And then, you know, because,
cause he's had so many
bad things happen to him
during his childhood,
he becomes kind of the lone gamer warrior
that we all think is
the coolest thing ever.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But you know-
- The black swordsman.
- Yeah, the black swordsman, right?
The guy who can carry
the big ass sword that-
- Not Kiruto.
- Isn't that Kiruto.
- The one who can just
beat everyone alone, right.
And, and you know,
he slowly realize that
that's a bit of an empty life
and wants to make friends.
And then bad things happen.
Very bad things happen and
bad things continue to happen.
And it's about getting
over those bad things
and trying to learn to accept people
and love again I supposed in certain ways.
- It poses itself as this
like big bad guy with a sword
fights monsters and bad dudes
and tries to survive them all.
But at the end of it, you realize,
"Oh, it's not about that."
It's about his journey.
- Yeah, it's always always about that.
It's always about the journey.
- It's about him.
It's literally just like
a manga about his life.
- Yeah and just the cherry
on top is just God tier art.
- God tier.
- The art is just insane.
Like it's, it's just the-
- [Joey] No one can draw like Miura.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And if you haven't read it, you know,
I had not read it for a very long time.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I knew it was good,
but I just didn't do it.
- You didn't know how good it was.
- I didn't know how good it was.
I mean I had watched the anime
and I thought, "Oh it's pretty good yeah.
It's good, this thing
is pretty all right."
- Okay wait, the 2016 anime?
- No the-
- Or the 90's?
- 90's anime.
- Oh okay. I was about to fucking say-
- That's what I was going to say.
- We don't do that here.
- We do not do that here.
(everyone laughs)
- And yeah, I read it.
And I'm saying like,
if you're sleeping on it or
you've been putting it off,
like now is the time like, you know,
while it's still fresh in
everyone's hearts you know.
It's pay tribute to the king, read it.
It's amazing.
You will not regret it.
Like it has, dare I say, a
little something for everybody.
- I mean, there's a reason why-
- Whatever you want out of a manga,
I guarantee you'll get
something out of this.
- There's a reason why-
- You will get something out of this.
- It's been goaded forever now.
- Yeah.
- It is not just like over-hyped at all.
It is-
- Rightfully deserved.
- It is, it is not over-hyped.
And I've thought of every
possible reason I could
to not put this on my three-by-three,
because it's just like,
it's just the one that-
- I think we all know that we
were all going to put it in.
- It's just like the manga
that goes on everyone's three-by-three
and I'm just like,
"Can I be that person?"
Yes, Miura deserves it.
- I've had many manga
that I, well not many,
most that I've had one or two
chapters that I have, like,
you know what, let's just
kind of speed run this part.
Let's get through it fast.
- Yeah.
- I never, ever, ever felt
like that during "Berserk."
Even though I'd seen the first arc.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I still was like, "Fuck this is good.
Taking my time."
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Like what I find
incredible is that, you know,
people will look at "Berserk"
or people who have never read "Berserk",
they look at it and they see,
"Oh, musty man with big sword go burr."
You know, that's kind of
like what it looks like
on the cover, but like what everyone
who's read "Berserk" and the moments
that stand out in "Berserk" and the parts
that people remember are
always like the quiet moments.
- Yeah.
- It's the beautiful moments.
And that's because
there's the juxtaposition
between like the fucked
up shit that happens
and the bloody and gory and amazing action
that is in the manga.
Like it's juxtaposed with some of like
the most beautiful moments
you can find in fiction.
- [Joey] Just the scene of Guts
standing in the field of flowers.
- [Connor] Yeah, that whole
like mini arc, if you will,
was one of my favorite moments reading it.
So I was like,
"Oh shit."
They just took like...
They were like, "Hold up."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Let's bring feels.
- Yeah, because I feel like,
I feel like the story of "Berserk" speaks
to just a core that so
many people can relate to
like, to, you know, to get
fucking real for a second.
Like if you've ever felt lost in life
or you don't know what your purpose is,
or you don't know-
- If it's worth it-
- If you don't know if it's
worth or why you're here.
Like if you're just ever having a bad day,
like that's exactly what Guts
goes through in "Berserk."
He may look like a big muscly man,
but he like,
the journey that he goes through
is exactly the same realization
that a lot of us have gone through
in our lives, you know.
- Under that hunk of
muscle, there is a heart.
- You can't chop your way
through every problem.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's what, you know-
- He tries and he realizes no he can't.
- As much as we'd all love
to be the overpowered MC
like at the end of the day
that this is not going to
help you solve every problem.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- That's what, you
know, does it shows you,
I guess in some ways not to
get too lost in the things
that are right in front of you, right.
Which is a lot about
what "Berserk" is about.
- Yeah, I think the scene that
sold me on "Berserk" if like,
if I can get to do some,
like small spoilers
of the Golden Age arc,
it's like the scene after he beats
like the hundred men.
Because like you, you think in warfare,
you have one man takes on a hundred men.
That's fucking bad ass.
- Yeah.
- In any other anime that would like,
that's framed as like, "Holy fuck."
This is an incredible feat, which it is.
And like, I remember like
it was just Guts' reaction.
It was just realizing it
doesn't fucking mean anything.
- And also the aftermath of
everyone coming in the forest
and seeing him just
murdered a hundred people.
They were just like disgusted.
They're like, "What the fuck?"
- How is this man alive?
- Yeah.
- Like what the fuck?
- But yeah, it's afterwards
that he just realizes,
"I'm doing this for no reason.
I'm literally just killing a hundred men
and it just means nothing to me."
- Yeah like even right away.
Like even though I, you know,
I think I said this in the last episode,
the last time we spoke about "Berserk."
I do think that I would have
preferred the first part,
which they because they
have like a time skip.
I would've preferred they've just put that
in the right time because
I feel like it kind of-
- Just start from like Golden Age arc.
- Yeah, I think it would have been perfect
to start from there.
Even though I'm sure
people disagree with me.
'Cause I feel like you get so
many really cool experiences
if you didn't know what
was going to happen.
And also just getting to see his childhood
from the start would
tell you all about the
how fucked up this thing is going to be.
- I guess they needed a hook, right.
- Yeah.
- To sell people in.
- I think so.
I think that's why, but like, you know,
I wonder if it was done again, you know,
would it be ordered differently?
Looking back I wonder.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
That's obviously just pure
speculation and I'm sure people
would completely disagree
with me and that's fine.
That's opinions, right?
That's what we're here for.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I think especially is
especially what happened recently.
"Berserk"'s really changed my perspective
on how I view media as well,
because I'm just like before,
I'm just like something
that's not finished
can't be a masterpiece.
And then I think about it
and I'm just like "Berserk"
is a pure example of
something that has done more
than fucking enough to be a masterpiece.
- [Connor] Yeah true.
- Like an unfinished masterpiece
is still a masterpiece.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And I feel like that's
really changed my perspective
on other shows, which maybe not have ended
and may never end.
And I'm just like, well,
I think it's still done enough
to be called like a masterpiece.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- And I think "Berserk" has
really shown me that as well.
- [Connor] I agree.
- Yeah.
- Read "Berserk."
Please.
And listen to Guts's theme.
- Even if you're not into dark
fantasy, I think it's still-
- I'm not in the dark fantasy.
- I still think it can
be very much enjoyed.
- I love dark fantasy.
- I mean, I guess there's
nothing else to say really.
- There's nothing else. That was-
- You've had some new recommendations.
- You know what Garnt, not bad.
I mean, let's take into
consideration this middle one.
- Get that shit out of here.
- Other than that, good choice.
Good Choice.
- Anyone who's read "Domestic Girlfriend"
knows that this shit slapped.
- Yeah, let us know your
three-by-three on the subreddit.
- [Garnt] I'm sure you will anyway.
- Because we'd love to see...
Like I need more recommendations.
- I'm wondering how many people
will have "Berserk" on there?
- I'm saying, man, like-
- [Connor] Listen it's-
- I want to see a three-by-three
that doesn't have "Berserk."
- It's not normy to put
"Berserk" in your three-by-three.
- It's not overrated.
It's just that good.
- It's like you know putting a salt
in my favorite condiments.
It's like, it needs to go on everything.
Like what do you, I'm not, come on.
Don't boo me, I'm right.
- It's like a three-by-three
of essential things.
I put water.
Water is overrated.
- Water, really?
Wow, you really put in water, wow.
I think Fanta belongs in but no water.
But, yeah anyway...
Yeah, please send us your three-by-three's
in the subreddit.
Go follow us on Twitter and Joe,
you can go and do the rest of this.
- Okay, well hey, let's
talk about our patrons.
First of all.
- Oh yeah, let's do that.
- Let's bring them up
on the screen right now.
- I bet they have good taste in manga.
- I'm sure they have good taste in manga.
- This guy right here has
a great taste in manga.
- I'm sure Grant Gaylord
has great taste in manga.
I love that boy.
- He has "Domestic
Girlfriend" in his manga.
- Oh God.
- I know he does.
- But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit
or your three-by-threes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
- [Connor] Cheers gamers.
- [Garnt] I honestly like there
weren't too many surprises.
This episode.
- You know what, we went from trash today.
- Just a good conversation.
- We weren't "Trash Taste."
We were great taste.
- We were gentlemen tastes.
- Yeah gentleman taste.
- Refined taste.
- What a nice episode
with minimal arguing.
- Exactly.
- Next week.
- I don't know.
I just feel like manga.
There's so much less variation in taste
because everyone knows what-
- We just like good things.
- If there's a good manga,
like everyone can kind of
agree it's a good manga.
No one reads like 200
chapters of something
that they are not enjoying.
- True.
- So yeah, that's been this
episode of "Good Taste."
- I guess we'll see you guys soon.
- All right, bye.
- Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
(upbeat music)